power bi is a leading business
intelligence tool for performing data
analysis creating data visualizations
and generating reports according to the
Gartner 2021 magic quadrant report for
analytics and business intelligence
platforms Microsoft power bi is a leader
hi everyone welcome to this live session
on power bi full course tutorial by
simply loan before we begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply loan Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
so in this video we will learn what
power bi is and explore the crucial
features
you will understand the different
components of power bi and how to
connect data sources to power bi desktop
you will learn to manipulate the data
and create different charts and graphs
you will understand how to use Dax
functions to derive value out of your
data
you will look at the difference between
power bi and tableau you will learn
about data modeling and create different
reports on power bi desktop finally in
this tutorial you will understand how to
create a really interesting and Powerful
dashboard and publish it onto the power
bi service so let's begin business
intelligence is a set of processes and
techniques to analyze raw data and
extract information that helps Drive
business decisions it helps you keep
track of business data and draw valuable
insights there are several tools that
play a key role in business intelligence
some of the popular tools are power bi
Tableau and click view in this video you
will learn why power bi is needed what
is power bi the various features of
power bi and the different components of
power bi later you will look at the
architecture of power bi what power bi
services and how to create a power bi
dashboard finally you will understand a
case study on Meyer and do a demo using
power bi now let's understand why power
bi is needed first Power bi has the
ability to access vast volumes of data
from multiple sources it allows you to
view analyze and visualize huge
quantities of data that cannot be opened
in Excel some of the important data
sources available in power bi are Excel
CSV XML Json PDF Etc second power bi
provides an easy to use drag and drop
tool with features and functionalities
that allow you to copy all formatting
across similar visualizations power bi
has exceptional integration with Excel
it helps you gather analyze publish and
share Excel business data power bi helps
to accelerate Big Data preparation with
Azure using power bi with Azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data as your data Lake can reduce the
time it takes to get insights and
increase collaboration between business
analysts data engineers and data
scientists power bi allows you to get
insights from data and turn insights
into actions to take data-driven
business decisions finally power bi
allows you to perform real-time stream
analytics it fetches data from multiple
sensors and social media sources to get
access to real-time analytics so you are
always ready to make business decisions
now let's see what power bi is power bi
is a business analytics service provided
by Microsoft that lets you visualize
your data and share insights it converts
data from different sources to build
interactive dashboards and bi reports as
you can see we have an Excel data about
sales using this data power bi helps you
build different charts and graphs to
visualize the data now that we have
understood what power bi is let us look
at the important features of power bi
first is power bi desktop power bi
desktop is a free software that you can
download and it allows you to build
reports by accessing data easily for
using power bi desktop you do not need
Advanced report designing or query
skills to build a report second as
already discussed power bi supports
stream analytics from Factory sensors to
social media sources power bi assists in
real-time analytics to make timely
decisions third support for multiple
data sources is one of the major
features of power bi you can access
various sources of data such as Excel
CSV SQL Server web files Etc to create
Interactive visualizations and finally
custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs let
us jump into discussing the various
components of power bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and mashup engine it
enables you to discover connect combine
and refine data sources to meet your
analysis need it can be downloaded as an
add-in for Excel or can be used as part
of power via desktop second we have
power pivot power pivot is a data
modeling technology that lets you create
data models it also allows you to
establish relationships and create
calculations it uses data analysis
expression language or Dax to model
simple and complex data third we have
power view Power view is a technology
that is available in Excel SharePoint
SQL server and power bi it lets you
create interactive charts graphs maps
and other visuals that brings your data
to Life Next we have power map
Microsoft's power map for Excel and
power bi is a 3D data visualization tool
that lets you map your data and plot
more than a million rows of data
visually on Bing maps in 3D format from
an Excel table or data model in Excel
then we have power bi desktop power bi
desktop is a development tool for power
query power pivot and Power view with
power bi desktop you have everything
under the same solution and it is easier
to develop bin data analysis experience
finally we have power Q and A the Q and
A feature in power bi lets you explore
your data in your own words it is the
fastest way to get an answer from your
data using natural language an example
could be what was the total sales last
year once you have built your data model
and deployed that into Power bi website
then you can ask questions and get
answers easily now let's see what power
bi service is power bi service is the
software as a service part of power bi
it is also referred as power bi online
to access power bi service you need to
log into app.powerbi.com now let me show
you that I'll go to Google
open a new tab and search for app dot
power bi
.com
it's loading
but this is how the home page of power
bi service looks like I have created
some dashboards on it first you need to
log into app.power bi service you can
see I'm logged in
now under my workspace if I go to
dashboard here I've created a finance
dashboard you can see the different
charts and graphs I have prepared and
pinned it to the dashboard so power bi
service allows you to connect to your
data create reports and dashboards and
you can also ask questions to your data
as you can see in this dashboard we have
created some charts and graphs so this
is a tree map there's a pie chart
there's a bar graph below you can see
the line charts and donut charts it
tells you the total sales that were made
the total number of units solds the
sales by product sales by country sales
by segment and lots more one of the key
features of power bi is creating
dashboards from multiple reports and
data sets power bi dashboard is a single
page visualization to tell a story The
visualizations on a dashboard are
generated from multiple reports and each
report is based on one data set a single
page dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualizations you see on the dashboard
are called tiles these tiles are pinned
to the dashboard by report designers now
let me go back to my dashboard so this
is called a canvas and each of these are
called tiles so on the top you can see
we have three tiles now let's understand
how to create and publish reports in
power bi dashboards power bi allows you
to create different reports on power bi
desktop these reports can be published
on the power bi dashboard using power bi
service here you can see there is a
power bi report created on power bi
desktop if you click on publish it will
take you to the power bi service where
you can build a dashboard here is the
button for power bi publish once you
click on power bi publish it will take
you to the dashboard so this is a single
page power bi dashboard on power bi
service now let's understand the power
bi architecture power bi architecture is
a service built on top of azure there
are multiple data sources that power bi
can connect to power bi desktop allows
you to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set Power via
Gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations using
power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for Windows
IOS and Android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how Meyer which is
one of United States largest Supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially Meyer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for it to build every report
Meyer was unable to perform ad hoc and
real-time analysis easily so what Maya
did was it connected power bi to an
on-premises SQL Server analysis Services
Cube this allowed them to refresh 20
billion rows of data in near Real Time
with power bi teams can now pull in the
data faster and perform real-time
analysis to derive insights from data a
bakery department inside Meyer used
power bi to compare its sales with
regional performance they analyzed where
Meyer was behind the regional Trends
focused on the problem and created a
solution with power bi they can now
drill down into hourly sales and send
out a sales flash to 800 Mayo Business
Leaders so power bi enabled them to
standardize data sources and Empower
store directors and team leaders to
develop and track their data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical Hands-On demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data View and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables on the right you can
see the different visualizations that
you can build we'll quickly run through
all of these in our demo
so here you can see there's a finance
sample data that will help you draw
insights about the sale of products in
different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data Tab and choose Excel as my data
source I click on Excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if I go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has Fields
such as segment country in which the
Salesforce made the name of the product
the unit sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building a report
now I'll go to my report view so first
let me create a text box
let me resize it
let me name it as
Finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use Font Consolers
Center it will also add a background to
this we use blue color change it to
White
and increase the size now let me first
show you how you can create a matrix
I'll go to visualizations and click on
Matrix let me resize it
from the datasheet tab I'll select sales
and drag onto values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so I'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and let me increase the
text size to 20. similarly under values
we'll increase the size of the text to
20 as well we can also click on border
and choose the color of the Border we
take as Let It Be black so this is a
simple Matrix that we created which
shows the total number of sales that
were made similarly let me choose Matrix
once again now we'll drag on the unit
sold onto values we'll continue with the
same drill under column headers We'll
add a background this time let's show
some other color and under values let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
even for the column headers let's
again we'll switch on Border let me
resize a bit
so here we have two Matrix created for
our report the first Matrix shows us the
total sales that were made the second
Matrix shows you the total units that
were sold now let's move ahead and
create a simple bar chart so under
visualization I click on clustered
column chart
under this we'll drag the date column
onto access and the sales onto value let
me expand it so it shows you the sales
per year this is the sales that were
made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014. now
there's a drill down option which gives
you more granularity
this depicts the sales per quarter if I
drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like sort by sort by
sales so you can see October month with
the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments under visualization
I'll click on pie chart let me first
resize it
here
I'll drag the segment column onto the
legend and the sales column onto the
values as you can see we have the sales
made by different segments dubman
segment made the highest number of sales
with 44.22 percent now let me add a
border to both the visualization I'll
click on the pie chart and go to the
format tab I'll switch on the border
similarly for the clustered column chart
I'll go to the format Tab and click on
border now let me resize a bit alright
next we'll create a very simple table
that will depict the total sales made by
each product so under visualizations I
click on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet I'll first drag
product onto values you can see the
different products and then sales just
below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here now let's do some formatting
under format tab I'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15. I'm expand
it also under column headers I'll
increase the text size to 15. then let
me go and add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization I'll click
on map now I'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if I move the
map you can see the sales made in the
Europe region
let me resize it I'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment under visualizations I'll
click on donut chart
and move this to the top now from the
data sheet I'll add profit onto the
values and segment
onto the legend
if I expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent let me resize
this and we'll add a border
okay in the final visualization I'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations I'll click on the tree
map let me expand it
I'll drag sales onto values and product
onto group so here you can see our tree
map and the sales made by each product
you can see now we have a report ready
we have created two separate canvas to
visualize our data now if you want to
change the color of these parts you can
simply go to the format Tab and under
data colors you can choose whichever
color you want in power bi desktop you
have an option to switch your theme this
will make your dashboard or the report
look more attractive so now we are under
the default mode Let's try out different
themes that's Frontier temperature solar
which is a little yellowish the one
which I like is tidal I hope this was
helpful in making you understand the
basics of power bi and how it works you
learn the various features and the
components of power bi and looked at the
architecture of RBI finally you saw a
demo to create a report using Finance
data set in this video we will learn
about the two important data
visualization and business intelligence
tools namely power bi and tableau
this video will help you learn the major
differences between the two tools first
we will look at the history of power bi
and Tableau followed by their cost then
we will see which of them has better
performance and a good user interface
after that we will look at the different
data sources to which power bi and
Tableau can connect with next we will
get an understanding of the programming
languages that they support and the data
visualization capabilities
you will then get an idea of how power
bi and Tableau support machine learning
and which of them has better customer
support
you will see the current trends of both
the tools and you will understand where
these tools are positioned in the
Gartner magic warden for 2020
finally I will tell you how simple learn
can help you start your career in power
bi and tableau now let's begin with
understanding the history of power bi
and tableau
so what really is power bi
bubble bi is a business analytics
service provided by Microsoft it has the
capability to analyze and visualize data
extract insights and share it across
various departments within your
organization it can also build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks
so power bi was originally designed by
Ron George in the summer of 2010 and the
initial release was available for public
download on 11th of July 2011.
the key components of power bi are power
bi desktop power bi service power bi
mobile apps power bi Gateway and power
bi report server
Tableau Software was founded in 2003 in
Mountain View California and the Tableau
desktop 1.0 was released in 2004 on 1st
of August 2019 Salesforce acquired
Tableau Tableau products include Tableau
desktop Tableau server W online W
visible W public and Tableau reader
now let's see how expensive these tools
are
power bi is way less expensive than
Tableau Software power bi professional
version costs less than 10 dollars per
month per user the yearly subscription
comes around hundred dollars
power bi premium is licensed with
dedicated Cloud compute and storage
resources and is priced at
4995 dollars per month
on the other hand
table Tableau is more expensive where
the pro version of Tableau comes at more
than 35 dollars per month per user
the yearly subscription costs around
thousand dollars Tableau Creator costs
around 70 dollars per month while
Tableau viewer is priced at 12 per month
if you are a startup or a small business
you can offer power bi and then upgrade
to Tableau if the need arises
now coming to Performance
power bi is easy to use it is faster and
performs better when the volume of data
is limited power bi tends to drag slow
when handling bulk data
but Tableau can handle large volumes of
data easily it is faster and provides
extensive features for visualizing the
data Tableau doesn't limit the number of
data points in a visualization or
enforce row or size limitations
so you can have a complete view of your
data tableau's wide range of built-in
analytic capabilities allows you to
spend less time worrying about manually
creating calculations designing
visualizations and formatting dashboards
now let's discuss the user interface of
these tools
the user interface of power bi is highly
intuitive and it can easily be
integrated with other Microsoft products
power bi interface is easy to learn and
understand
it is user friendly and allows you to
operate better power bi desktop provides
three views which you can select on the
left side of the canvas
the first view is of the report View
where you can create reports and visuals
the next is the data View
in this view you can see the tables
measures and other data used in the data
model associated with your report
and transform the data for best use in
the reports model
and third is the model view in this view
you can see and manage the relationships
among data in your data model
Tableau has an intelligent interface
that enables you to create and customize
the dashboards according to your
requirements easily
it has an inviting workspace area that
encourages you to experiment with data
and get smart results
the workspace area has different cards
and cells toolbar sidebar data source
page status bar and Sheet tabs
with that let us now talk about the
different data sources that power bi and
Tableau can connect with
another important feature of power bi is
that it supports various data sources
but has limited access to other
databases and servers compared to
tableau
some of the examples are Microsoft Excel
text or CSV files folders Microsoft SQL
Server access DB Oracle database IBM db2
mySQL database post query SQL database
Etc
Tableau Software has access to numerous
data sources and servers such as Excel
text file PDF Json statistical file
Amazon redshift Cloudera Hadoop Google
analytics Dropbox Google Sheets Google
Drive and lots more
now let's talk about that ease of use
power bi enjoys a slight Edge in terms
of ease of use because it is based on a
user interface that has its roots in
Microsoft Office 365.
which most end users are already
familiar with
Tableau provides some essential
advantages for exploring and visualizing
data in detail Tableau is also
incorporating natural language
capabilities into its software
this will help us in finding solutions
to complex Problems by understanding the
data better
next let us understand how power bi and
Tableau differ in terms of programming
support
power bi supports data analysis
expressions or Dax and M language for
data manipulation and data modeling it
can connect with our programming
language using Microsoft Revolution
analytics but it is available only for
Enterprises level users
compared to power bi
Tableau integrates much better with our
language
Tableau Software development kit can be
implemented using any of the four
programming language such as C C plus
plus Java and python by connecting to
these programming languages you can
build even more powerful visualizations
now coming to the most important
category which is data visualization
power bi provides an easy to use drag
and draw functionality it provides
features that make data visually
appealing
power bi offers a wide range of detailed
and attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards
using power bi service you can ask
questions about your data and it will
give you meaningful insights
tab blue also allows its users to
customize dashboards specifically for a
device it delivers interactive visuals
that support insights on the Fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and makes you ask
questions spot Trends and identify
opportunities no coding knowledge is
required to work on Tableau as Tableau
provides inbuilt table calculations to
build reports and dashboards
now talking about machine learning and
how they are different from each other
power bi enjoys the advantages of
Microsoft business analytics that
includes platforms such as Azure machine
learning SQL Server based analysis
Services data streaming in real time and
many Azure database offers
it helps to understand the data and
analyze the trends and patterns in the
data you can also forecast the data to
make future predictions
table Tableau supports the features of
python machine learning this enables it
to perform machine learning operations
over the data set
finally let's talk about customer
support
Microsoft power bi is relatively younger
in the market than Tableau and hence it
has a smaller community
while Tableau has over 160 000 active
users participating in over 500 Global
user groups and over 150 000 active
customers participating in the Tableau
online community
next on the screen you can see the
Google trends for both the tools Over
The Last 5 Years From 2015 onwards
as you can see Tableau is a clear front
runner and is more popular these days
with high search volume
now talking about the Gartner magic
quadrant for analytics and business
intelligence platforms
so for 13 consecutive years Gartner has
recognized Microsoft as a magic quadrant
leader in analytics and business
intelligence platforms
and it has recognized Tableau as a
leader in business intelligence after
Microsoft
you can see there are other popular
tools such as click hotspot seasons
sap and Salesforce
now I will tell you how simply learn can
assist you in learning power bi in
Tableau and help you become an expert in
business intelligence
so let me take you to our website
I'll open a new tab
let me search for simplylearn.com
I'll Now search for Power bi in the
search bar so let me type power bi here
I'll click the first link
which is the power bi certification
training course
so this course
will help you learn about Microsoft
power bi desktop layouts
you will learn how to build business
intelligence reports dashboards power bi
data analysis Expressions commands and
functions
so this is the course content
so you learn about desktop layout
features the views connecting to Common
data sources we learn about the query
editor
and its functionality then you will
learn how to create relationships in
your data model
you learn about calculated columns and
measures built-in aggregations
we'll also learn about data
visualizations practices reports and
dashboard layout creating a sales
analysis report and lots more
let me go back
and now I'll search for tableau
I'll click on the first link
so this is the course for Tableau
certification training
so it's around 56 hours of in-depth
Blended learning there are four
real-time industry projects
you'll get lifetime access to self-piece
learning videos to simulation exams
on the right you can see the skills that
will be covered as part of this course
we learn Tableau statistics building
interactive dashboards this arithmetic
logical and LOD calculations which is
level of detail learn about heat map
waterfall
Pareto clustering forecasting
and here you can see the entire course
content
after learning this course you can go
ahead and take the Tableau certification
what is power bi it is a business
intelligence tool to visualize your data
and share insights across your
organization so when we talk about bie
it came into existence as a self-service
bi tool and it does have different
components which can be used now before
we get into details of power bi let's
understand what are the different
components or what are the different
ways in which you can work on your power
bi now one of the main challenges when
it comes to
organizations or users is that data is
scattered in different places it might
be in different formats and anyone
everyone would want to use that data to
basically perform some calculations
create visualizations or dashboards
which could be interactive and that's
where they would want to bring all the
data in one place might be transform it
so that you can filter out and not load
huge amount of data in your system and
you can work on selective data so when
it comes to power bi it helps us in ETL
it helps us in data modeling it helps in
data storage and Reporting now before we
get further into understanding how power
bi looks like it would be good idea to
share information in how you can set
that up on your machine so when it comes
to your power bi and let me open up a
notepad here
so for example I bring up a notepad
let's say when you talk about your power
bi components
so you basically have
power bi desktop
and that's mainly your playground or
that's mainly used for any kind of
development activities
you have your power bi server
or you can say service so now this one
is where you would make reports
online
and share
or make them available
to different views
now that's one more component of power
bi and then you also have your power bi
mobile which is mainly for viewing the
information or I would say viewing
reports so these are the three main
components we can also look at the
licensing information of these so these
are the main so power bi desktop is
something which you can set up on your
laptop or on your machine power bi
server is where you can log in with your
user ID and password and power bi mobile
is mainly to view your reports now how
do you set this up before you can
explore or start working on power bi so
here is a link which you can basically
use so if you look into this so this one
basically says Service cell service sign
up for power bi it says sign up of power
bi Service as an individual normally
when you would want to use power bi you
can use a website called stdp and then
you have basically
app
and let's say
I think it's called app powerbi.com now
this is the place where you can
basically log in now if you see here I
have created an account and if you look
at my account it says auatl dot on
microsoft.com now how do you get this
kind of email because when you talk
about power bi it will expect you to
have a official ID and it does not take
IDs which are from common domains such
as Google or Yahoo and so on so this
particular link gives you an idea how
you can do that so basically you have
what is power bi basic explanation on
that it says signing up for power bi
service so power bi desktop it's a
totally free download and then you have
mobile apps also a totally free download
and here it says
that what kind of email addresses it
supports and if we look into this you
have to either sign up because that does
not accept your private email IDs or you
can go for this one which says enroll US
government organization and this is
where you can basically sign up for
power bi so it basically says try free
if you go to the website say power
bi.microsoft.com or you could go into
this one which I was saying HTTP slash
slash app Dot
your powerbi.com and this is what you
can use or as mentioned you can go to
powerbi.microsoft.com for example if I
open this in a different tab
it takes me to about via Microsoft I can
say start free I can click on this
it says Drive free but then when it asks
you to sign in this is where some of us
face problem because it does not take
your private email ID now how do you
tackle that what you can do here is on
this page which says learn about
alternate ways to sign up you can
basically open up this link and in this
link it says sign up for power bi with a
new Microsoft 365 trial account and what
you can do is you can basically click on
this link which takes you to The Office
365 and what you can do here is you can
search for something which says say 365
E3 and here you have tried for free
so in my case it is translating okay so
here you have an option which says try
it for free click on this one and then
basically go ahead with your sign up
process now once you do that you can
basically create an account or give a
email ID so it asks you to give an email
ID to check if you already have an
account and once you do that it will
guide you through the process where you
can create an account like I have done
now once you have done that so for
example we can go into my this page
which I said HTTP slash slash app
powerbi.com
now once you have created an account you
would be asked to log in now I can click
and log in here and then basically given
my password and once I do that it takes
me to the power bi server or service now
on the top right it might say that go
for a trial version I have already
selected that and this is a Pro trial
which is giving me validity for 60 days
so this is the service which I can use
now what it means is I can be using my
power bi desktop which would be also
installed so once you log into this page
you can basically click on apps you can
basically search for something like
power bi and that will show up in the
app and you can install and download on
your machine now once that is there you
can basically bring it up so for example
in my case I can just say power bi
desktop and that's the app which I have
installed on my machine and basically
that comes up so that's your power bi
desktop which is coming up and it will
still ask you to sign in so that you can
share your information through Power bi
so you see here on the top I'm already
signed in and here it also shows you
some tutorials and videos which
basically helps you in getting to know
something more or what's new so you can
always browse that so you would have
your power bi desktop which would be set
up
you would also have your power bi
service which would be running and then
basically whatever you have developed on
your power bi desktop you can share that
through the power bi service now usually
when you talk about licensing I can give
you brief insights here so you basically
have your power bi Service as I said
licensing so you have the pro version
which is basically
of your 9.9 dollars
per user per month
and basically it has some kind of
limitation so it has say Max 10 gigabyte
you can work on uh some features like
incremental refresh is not allowed you
can always look onto the Microsoft
website for more details and in those
kind of cases you usually go for the
premium account if you are a extensive
user and premium account basically is
conditional based so it depends on your
requirements and then basically you pay
for the service what you use so that's
mainly about your servicing now when you
talk about your server and Service as I
said it is basically making your reports
online and sharing and making them
available to different bus so that is
the Highlight so when you talk about
sharing reports that's one of the things
you have and normally detection
that's also possible here you can talk
about automation of reports you have
security that is you can go for role
based or row level based kind of
security implementation and all those
are some of the features of your power
bi server and service so it is good to
know and basically have your desktop and
power bi service set up now once you
have that then you basically have your
power bi now when you talk about your
power bi it basically helps you with
various things so this is how easily you
can have it set up and then basically
you can explore this so for example as I
was saying power bi can connect to
different data sources now I do have an
option here which says get data I can
click on this and that shows me all the
different data sources I can even click
on more if I'm interested in looking
what more power bi desktop tool helps me
to do so it shows me all the different
ways in which you can get the data you
see here the servers so the database
Services your folders your different
formats you can click on file formats or
databases you can look at Power Platform
so if basically you are connecting to a
platform and getting some Services you
can connect to the cloud that is azure
you have online services and then you
have other options so these are all the
ways in which you can get your data when
you talk about visualizations you see a
lot of visualization options here which
can be used once your data is loaded and
I will explore and explain more about
this so you have something called as
insert wherein you can go in for
different visuals or different types you
can also get into say transform the data
now that basically is going to pop up
and bring a power query editor now
that's where a lot of your ETL Works
happen so when you when you do a
transform data it opens a power query
editor which we can use to transform the
data or change the data or modify the
data as per our requirement before
loading all of it into our power bi
so you also have option here which says
modeling wherein we can create new
tables or we can work on our data where
we can manage relationships so as of now
we don't have any data so it does not
show this one is activated but that can
be activated this is where you can view
your reports so this is in short
exploring your power bi we'll see what
are the different options which we can
use here so it basically supports
different kind of data so when we look
at the visualization pane that
basically allows us to create different
kind of visualizations here and we will
understand that so you can basically
visualize on your different data and
create different kind of charts graphs
maps and basically derive insights from
your data now when you talk about data
models that's where you can basically
establish relationships so when you talk
about data models it is basically used
to connect multiple data sources to
build a relationship now we might have
different data sets or we might have
data coming in from different tables
where we may want to basically
get insights or get data from multiple
data sources
for our purpose now in that case data
models to help us so for example if you
have two tables let's look at the
standard tables so you have products
lookup table and you also have the sales
table now usually what you have in any
kind of scenario is if we basically say
you have your data tables so that's
basically where your data resides and
then you have series of your lookup
tables so usually you might have say
your data tables here
and this is what I am talking about
which might have some data for example
let's say sales is one of them you might
have some other data table which might
be for example let's say budget table
or maybe something else and these are
your data tables now at the other end
you might have your lookup tables so
basically you have various lookup tables
and these lookup tables for example
let's say this one is customer
this one is territory
let's say this is product
and let's say this one is a calendar
so these are basically my lookup tables
so we can basically as I said your data
might be coming in from different
sources let's say database or let's say
some kind of files or let's say some
kind of systems what you have so your
data might be coming in from different
places now you might want to transform
the data so this is where I could say
there is your query editor which I was
explaining so you have your query editor
which basically allows you to edit the
data table or basically allows you to
edit the data before it is loaded right
you can hide a column you can add a new
column you can modify your column so
your query editors would be basically
used to work on the data which goes into
your data tables now you might have a
lot of lookup tables as I said so let's
say these are my lookup tables
and these are my data tables so what we
need is sometimes we need information
based on our lookup tables and data
tables now that's where data modeling
comes into picture so basically if I
would want to extract information from
here so I can notice that there is a
product key here and there is a product
key here now this is where we are
already talking about say foreign keys
or we are talking about your
relationships right now when you talk
about relational databases you have
something called as foreign key
constraints which is in in power bi
terms I would say it's not exactly a
constraint but it is more of a filter
propagation instead which is used to
basically connect your different data
sources and you could have basically
cross filter directions you can go for
single or one to one or one too many or
many too many kind of relationships
which basically allows you to work on
the data so we will learn more about
data models when we are doing a quick
demo there where we can talk a little
bit about
normalization and denormalization the
way the data exists right and then you
basically would want to gather insights
from your data so when you talk about
your
two data sources as I said so you have a
products lookup table you have a sales
table now if you would want to calculate
the total order quantity of each product
name which is we are talking about the
order quantity as a information here and
you have product name here now how do
you get that information what we see
here is we would want something like
this or we would want more information
so how do we do that so what we can do
is the order quantity for each product
is basically showing us the same value
now this is because the product and
sales tables are not connected and there
is no relationship between them even if
you would want to take two sources and
just get information out of them
probably I would complain that there is
no relationship established between them
so what we do is we create a data model
so what we do is we build a relationship
between both the tables using a common
key column which exists in both cases as
I said there is a product key here there
is a product key here so that basically
allows us to have a relationship between
these two now that could be one to one
this could also be related to other
tables so it could be one to many you
could have many to one so all those
relationships are possible so product
key is basically used to create a
relationship you see the arrow Mark and
then there is also the star which can
basically mean one to many now when the
product key is used to join these two
tables or from a relationship then we
can look at the product names and the
order quantities which basically gives
me a total now that's the basic use of
your data models now what about this Dax
so basically data analysis Expressions
now that's a a library of functions and
operators that can be combined to build
formulas and expressions and power bi
desktop usually when we work on our data
sources when we would want to connect
them it automatically shows us this data
analysis Expressions however this gives
us extension it basically gives us more
power to work on our data you know
sometimes instead of working on Dax or
Dax Expressions it would be good to go
for better data modeling and have the
relationships established better and
sometimes when the relationships are
established you could use your tax which
basically gives you more power on
working on your data so your values are
calculated based on information from
each row of a table it appends values to
each row in a table and stores them in
the model it increases the file size so
that's what happens now you can right
click on any column to add a new column
and for example in this one it shows
that there was a quantity type
calculated column which was based on the
calculation what we see here on the top
in the in the expression bar which says
what kind of calculation was performed
and that basically gives us the value
for quantity type and that is basically
added here to are existing data
so that's the power of Dax and power bi
so you also have something called as
measures so Dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures so
basically here if you see we are working
on AW underscore sales and then we have
selected quantity sold and what we are
looking in the report is we can
basically right click on any table name
to add a new measure here so we have
added what we call as quantity sold as
the measure so values are calculated
based on information from any filters in
the report we will see this how this can
be done and that basically here the
measure does not increase the file size
it does not create new data in the table
themselves in comparison to what we were
seeing earlier that is your calculated
columns so these are your type of Dax
functions so Dax allows you to create
new calculated columns and measures so
you have date and time which basically
allows you to work on date and time data
or Fields you have logical functions
which allow us to create new filters or
add more filters to our data you have
text functions which basically allows us
to say transform the data into a lower
case or an upper case or basically get
the length of a string or concatenate
two fields or basically do a filtering
based on some criterias or replacing
some content you also have statistical
functions which can be used you have
information functions which can be used
so these are different types of Dax
functions which we can use in power bi
so we will learn more on power bi
through a quick demo where we can use
some data sets and those data sets could
be found on internet
although I can also upload that on a
GitHub link and you will have access to
those data sets so let's learn about
power bi through a quick demo by
uploading some data sets and playing
with those data sets let's look at a
sample data set and let's upload it
and as I explained while uploading let's
also transform the data so that we can
have selective fields or selected data
loaded here instead of loading the
complete data set and then let's see how
we can visualize this or how we can use
the information in this data set now
what we can do here is we can click on
get data and then we can choose one of
the data formats which we would be
looking for so for example I can go for
excel and basically
click on this now here are some of my
data sets so let's look into the folder
here and these data sets are also
available on my GitHub link which I'll
share with you later so here we have
something called a super store let's
click on this and here I already have a
data set which is global Superstore or I
also have selective data so let's select
this one click on open
now that's basically connecting to my
data source and that will show me what
does that Excel sheet have so it has
different tabs which is orders people
and returns so let's select orders
and that basically gives me a preview of
the data which I have and if you scroll
all the way to write it shows me city
state and then country and if you see
here we do see information of all the
countries now this can be huge amount of
data which may which we would want look
into but say for example my use case is
that I am interested in looking for the
data for United States and as a country
and all it states so we will do that
when we do a transform now we can also
select the returns Tab and that shows me
these three Fields however the first row
should have been the heading of this a
particular data set and we will
transform that now I can go ahead and
click on load but that will load all the
data so instead of that let's go for
transforming so let's click on transform
data now once you do that it brings you
your toolkit that brings you your power
query editor which allows you to
transform your data so for example we
have uh data from returns tab or returns
data source as you see here so we see
column one column two and column three
and that also shows the type of the data
here it also gives me a quick small
option here let's select this and then I
can say use first row as header now
there are various other options which
you can do you can add a custom column
you can add column with examples you can
keep the top rows you can remove the top
rows you can keep errors keep duplicates
so there are different ways and you can
also do a merge where you are append
query so as of now let's just say use
first row as headers and that basically
shows that now my first row has become
the header you also see in the applied
steps it basically tells me if I have
changed the type of the data if I have
made any other changes those steps will
get added here so it basically shows me
the name as it returns it shows me
applied steps where I've changed the
type and now I basically have this
information now this is something where
you can change the type or you can
basically set it to a particular format
however we are not doing anything of
that sort right now so we can do that
for any of these columns so this looks
good when it comes to orders let's click
on this and as I said I would be
interested in selecting for country as
United States only and let me just work
on that data however we can work on all
the data so let me scroll all the way to
right and here I have the country now
there are these filters which we can use
so basically I can click on this and
that shows me all the countries are
selected now there is also something
called as text filters which we will see
how we can use to select particular data
I basically have other ways of filtering
the data so for example now I will just
uncheck this select all and what I would
be interested is in United States so
let's type it here that shows me has an
option here select this and then
basically say okay
so that should basically now filter out
and it shows me the data is United
States only and then you have different
states and rest of the data remains so
if you look at the applied steps it
tells me that there are filtered rows
now we have done the basic
transformation for this data set
on these two data sources that is orders
and returns so here you have an option
which says close and apply so close the
query editor window and apply any
pending changes you can click on this
and it says apply so for example I can
just say apply for now and that should
basically apply the changes
which I have performed using my query
editor that is I have transformed the
data so that I can have selective data
uploaded in my power bi now it's showing
that it shows me it is working on both
of these data sources that is orders and
returns so that's done and now basically
if there are any other pending changes
we can just do a close and apply so that
basically has closed and now you would
see the data appearing here so I have
uploaded the data as per my preferences
now if you click on the data tab here so
it basically shows you your data fields
it might take some time to populate but
if you see in the country field now if
even if I click on the filter it just
shows me United States now that's what
we wanted so we have already uploaded
this data in orders you can always
expand the option here which shows me
all the fields which are there in this
might be this is an aggregation might be
that's an ordered date so this is again
some kind of aggregation we can change
the data types so we are looking at all
the fields in my order stable or
basically coming from the orders data
source I also have returns which shows
me three fields and that shows me the
data which is returned order ID and
region so the column names are applied
correctly as we want and that basically
looks fine now we can also look at your
model so when you click on model it
shows me these two however there is no
as of now relationship established
between them so it says under properties
select one or more model objects to set
their properties so right now these are
not related there is no relationship
established between them so if I would
want some data which relates to orders
and returns then that would fail because
it would say there is no relationship
now I can go to the first option which
says report and we have not created any
report here although we can create a
simple report we can look at the data so
we have our orders field now we can
basically pull out some information from
here we can choose what kind of report
we may want to create so for example
let's go for the table option from
visualizations you have various options
here which we can use this is where you
can do a formatting this is where you
can select the fields this is where you
can search and filter out the data you
can also add data fields here so first
let's click on table
and that basically gives me a table now
this table as of now does not have
anything so you can use the filter and
slices
option here which will affect the
visualization or basically what you can
do is now since we have orders here so
this is my orders and I would like to
work on this so let's say for example
country is I can select country as a
field and if you say it shows me country
is all as of now and it says the value
is United States what I can also do is
I'm interested in the states so I have
state now I can basically drag and drop
it here and then the state gets added
here so I can basically say select all
and that should basically take care of
my State field being added here so state
is all country is all now we can
basically look at something else so
might be let's choose sales and I can
just drag and drop sales here here so
that basically says if you would want to
have any kind of advanced filtering
which says filter type so go for
advanced filtering is less than or equal
or you can also go for advanced filters
so that's fine as of now so we have
added some Fields here and that's
basically
my data here so let's go for filters
here
which basically should select all my
fields
now if you see the visualization shows
my country sales and state which we had
either by selecting the fields and
dropping them here or you can in this
section where it says Fields so you can
for example let me show it again so I
can just delete this I can click on the
table option I can just drag it here I
can basically make it bigger and I need
to add data to this one so it says add
data fields here so now let's say
country is what we are interested in we
are also interested in States
so let's drop that here and let's say
sales so this is also what I'm
interested so I'm looking at one
specific country I'm looking at sales
per state and when we look at sales it
basically tells me that this is
summation so you will basically get the
total sales which have happened now we
are looking at this data here we can
always go to formatting we can click on
grid we can basically increase the font
here we can change the grid color so for
example let's make it for example blue
so I can just select this
and it should basically
allow me to have the grid color as blue
now I can go in for the grid thickness I
can go for row padding outline color so
we can basically make it a little bit
more readable and then we can basically
increase the font size here
to look at the information
and you have other options here so what
would you want to do with column headers
so I can basically have the font color
background color is fine do you want to
have an outline do you want to have a
change in font what is the text size
might be we can make the heading a
little bigger and then basically you
also have the field formatting so all
those could be done you could go for
background and all these things can be
done in formatting so now we already
have our data here and this basically
looks good and this is basically one of
my visuals which I have here and this
has given me some information for sales
and basically I can scroll this I can
also make it bigger
so I could select a particular field if
I'm more interested in looking at the
information for a particular State now I
can add more fields to this
so this is my one of the reports which I
have created now what I can do with this
report is I can basically have more data
fields I can add filters to this I can
basically look into all the data here by
just clicking somewhere in the grid but
somewhere outside if you select a
particular row then that data shows up
here you have an option of focus mode
which you can go for you can look at the
other options which says export data now
if this is the data which you are
interested in you can export it you can
always to show as a table if you are
interested in you can do a sort by
country sales or state so for example
let's do a sorting by state
and that basically gives me the data
which has been sorted by state
information now we could obviously have
the information here so I can then
change the order so it shows me
alphabetically this is the information
which I have so I've created a simple
visualization using the data which I
have and what I can do is I can click on
save so that basically asks me to save
this as a power bi file which has an
extension of pbix and I can basically
call it my report so let's say first
report and here I can say country or I
can say state
wise
sales in
USA
let's say
USA and that basically is my first
report
now
once you have saved this report you can
always look on your machine for example
if I go in here and if I go into this
folder might be I should look on desktop
and this is where I should have saved it
so it shows me first report statewise
that will open up in power bi and we
have created a simple report which we
have basically used by taking our data
now I can also do is I can publish this
if I would want to share this
information so publish this report
online in power bi service you can
basically select
your report what we have here and I
clicked on publish so it says what's the
destination so you can have different
workspaces I will choose the default
that's my workspace I can click on
select now it says publishing first
report Statewide sales in USA to power
bi you can create a portrait view of
your report and you can do all that
stuff so let it publish and then we can
basically look into our power bi server
that's our service where the information
is already shared
or published I would say which can then
be shared with different resources so we
can come here and basically I can look
into the power bi and this is where I
will be able to look into my workspaces
and let's look in my workspace so it
says this is the place where I had
initially downloaded power bi data set
it says your data set is ready let power
bi help you explore your data right so
you can always do this you can click on
view data set
which basically allows you to bring out
your workspace and first report State
why sales now that's the report which we
have published so let's first check in
our desktop if that's done so it says
success open first report in power bi
now I can click on this one straight
away and that takes me to my service now
once it takes me to the service it shows
me the report which we created which we
published and it basically has the
option where I can save it
as a a different copy or give a
different name I can embed this in the
in a website or a portal I can publish
to web
embed this report for Public Access by
anyone on the internet we can do that we
can export it to PowerPoint so we can do
all these options you also have an
option of view where you can change the
view you can basically also edit report
here so you can do that if you are
interested in something specific
you can do a sharing to teams so if you
have your teams or groups set up you can
share it with them you have an option of
common pains you can basically view
usage metrics report now that can be
sometimes helpful you can basically go
ahead and go and subscribe a particular
report so if there are new changes made
you will be the one who will be informed
you can click on share now if I click on
share here from my service it says only
users with power bi Pro will have access
to the support recipients will have the
same access as you unless row level
security on the data set further
restricts them so I can grant access and
this is where I will have to give the
email IDs of the people with a message
that I would want to have them
look at this report
right you can also allow recipients to
build new content using the underlying
data sets and you can send an email
notification to the users as of now I
don't have any other groups so I'll not
be sharing it but I have created a
simple report now let's also look at
edit report let's just to see what it
helps us and when you click on edit
report it basically brings up this one
which says your file view it gives you
the filters it basically
allows you to add data fields to this so
it is basically giving access to these
data sets which were in my desktop
it is basically allowing you to give or
create different visualizations now here
we have the data which we are looking at
and if say for example somebody is
interested in filtering the data so you
could do that so you could click on
filter here and that basically applies
this is the filter we have now country
is fine sales might be I can click on
sales and I would say okay let's look at
sales which is more than a particular
amount so we can say is greater than and
might be I can give a number here so I
can say 30
000.
and basically
I can say apply filter
so right now I'm applying filter and I
would look at the values which also
shows me the total value is changed so
you have not only created a report you
have published it and now
from the service you can edit it so I'm
looking at particular data here and then
basically I can click on file and I can
save it or I can say save a copy of the
report and let's say I will call it the
same name so I'll say first
report underscore
state wise sales and I will say modified
so let's do a save
and the report has been saved
so now you're looking at the data here
so that is basically giving you
information so when I click on my
workspace here
I can click on reports and that does
show me my previous report it shows me
the modified report it gives me an
option of looking at the usage metrics
report so say for example you want to
click on this one and it will basically
give you the usage metrics so let's
click on this one and that basically
shows me the report usage metrics which
is generated so views for day unique
viewers per day you would want to look
at the different platforms who was using
it views by user and this can be
sometimes useful if we would want to
look into this one now I can go back to
my workspace I can click on reports
and that basically took me to usage
metrics I could be sharing it I can
analyze in Excel I can look for quick
insights based on this data what we have
you can basically look at the related
information you can also look at the
settings of this one and basically this
is how you have your data report here
now that also shows me the data sets
option so which basically gives me
the data sets which can be used to
create further reports and we have our
data here
so
for example if I click on create report
it basically gives me these data sets
and we can continue working on this so
this is how I have a simple report
created without basically working on two
different data sources but I have
selected some data here and then I can
basically add details to this so for
example now if we look at orders and say
for example this is the data I have
and say you would want to add some
Fields so let's go to returns and say
for example I would be interested in
looking at the the products so might be
what I should do is I should replace the
report here instead of country it would
be interesting to look at the product
which we have or basically customer ID
so we can look at customer ID we can
look at the order ID which would be
interesting to see if there is a
particular order what was the sales
which was generated and if there were
any returns which were happening on that
so for example here when I have these
let me cut out country as a field and I
will basically take order ID and place
it here so now if you see my data has
been easily modified so I have my order
ID I have sales and I have statewise
information so you have basically all
the information but this is now order ID
State and so on now what if I would want
to also see
based on the order ID if I say I would
want the returned field
so for example I would want to take this
one and let's drag and drop it here now
that says cannot display the visual now
why is that so if you click on see
details that says cannot determine
relationships between the fields so it
cannot display the data because power bi
cannot determine the relationship
between two or more fields and how do we
fix that so for example if I click on
fix this now it says there is a missing
relationship between these fields use
Auto detect to search for relationships
or create them manually now I can click
on auto detect which will try to search
for fields which exist in both the data
sets or basically I can create
relationships so let's click on create
relationships and that basically takes
me to this page which says there are no
relationships defined
from table to table and so on so I can
click on new
now here it says select the tables and
the columns that are related now I can
say orders now those are my Fields where
you have order IDs and it automatically
shows that returns also has an order ID
field although all the values might not
be same but this is how you can create a
relationship and it says the cardinality
says many to one so you can have
basically many to one relationship you
are saying cross filter Direction is
single so make this relationship active
and it has already helped us basically
identifying the field so I can say okay
so it says now these two tables should
be related or should be connected based
on order ID so
here we have this and let's basically
say close
now once that is done if you see
I have order ID I have returned
I have sales column and I have state and
if you see in return I do have a value
of yes which shows this particular order
ID had generated some sales and it was
for state Alabama and it was returned
and the value is yes so if you scroll
down you basically see all the values
now we can add different filters where
we can say I would want only yes and no
now this is again an interesting report
so let's go in also into the formatting
and what we can do is we can look at say
the grid option if we would want to
basically say vertical grid and let's
say
on
and it says vertical grid color so let's
select this might be I can try doing a
black here it puts it in the right nice
table format and that basically looks
good so you have
sales returned and so on and this is
basically the order which I am seeing
here so for example if I would want to
change the order and if I'm saying okay
I would like to look at sales and
returned and so on so we can be doing
that we can come here and say for
example I have sales and returned let's
try moving the sales column over here
might be state is uh
and information which we would want in
the beginning so let me also move the
states all the way here so it gives me
state it gives me the order ID sales and
if there was a return which was
happening on that particular product so
easily I've modified my report now what
I can do is I can just save it
and I can do the same thing so I can
publish it I can basically continue
using it or I can work on a new report
so let's continue learning and now here
we will also see how you can load some
data and perform some Transformations
and basically get multiple results or
multiple tables or multiple data sets
which can be then further used for
reporting so power bi does give you a
lot of options now here you have an
option as we saw earlier that is get
data or what you can do is you have an
option where you can create new data
also which says enter data now this is
something which can be easily used if
you have relatively less number of
fields so you can basically add more
columns here and you can basically add
values so for example if I would just
call it something like
um scientist ID
okay and then I can say scientist name
and then basically I can say uh domain
and then I can say for example let's say
year of joining and and I can keep
adding the number of columns here I can
delete the columns right and I can give
this and I can say country
so that's it and now we have created
these five countries sorry five columns
which we have given some names and we
can start entering some values so I can
basically say let this scientist ID be
22 3 4 I can give some name so let's
give Peter let's say domain and I can
say biotechnology
I can give year of joining 2011 and I
can say Germany as the country
and I really don't want this particular
column so I can go ahead and delete this
now I can come here and then I can give
something else so I can say this is
scientist ID I can give John let's say
the scientist is mainly working in
physics
and then I can say 2018 and let's say
France
and go back here and let's say
four five six seven and let's say Marie
and let's say she does her research in
uh molecules and let's call it 2001 and
let's say
Italy
okay and you can continue adding data in
this way now you can say if the data is
already here so I can say for example no
I do not want this particular row
so you can basically keep adding values
here now you can say edit so here we
have to give some name so let's say
scientists
okay and then if you choose edit it
basically brings up your power bi editor
which allows you to work on these fields
if you would want to make some changes
now we can make some changes here we can
see what are the number of rows we can
basically perform any kind of
transactions here so this one basically
tells me what is the data type so here
we see scientist ID and this clearly
tells me this is an integer however we
will not want to do any kind of
computations here so we can as well
change this so I can just do a right
click and I can work on this particular
column what I can also do is I can just
click on this and this tells me that you
would want to change it to date time or
you want to change it to some number so
I can just say string because we are not
going to perform any computation here so
on the ID column so let say text and I'm
changing it so it says replace current
add a new Step so selected column has an
existing type conversion would you like
to replace the existing conversion or
preserve the existing so I will say
replace current and now the data type
has been changed it is of a string and
if you see this step has got added here
so it says that the change type
is the kind of transformation we did
here so that's fine now what we can also
do is we have the scientist name but we
don't like the column name here so it
would be good to change this
so there is something called as remove
or remove columns and so on so when you
do a right click it gives you a lot of
options in applying filters or doing
some transformation if I just click on
this one so what I can do is I can look
at the date time
and let's go here so we have an option
which says do you want to change the
type now we could have done that here or
like I said you could choose the time
and do it you can just say transform and
how do you want to change it so do you
want to change it to uppercase well you
can do that and changes all the values
of this one
what I can do is I can again do a right
click and I can choose basically if you
would want to clean up the data or if
you would want to convert to lowercase
you want to capitalize each word so
let's choose that and if you see here
the steps are getting added now to undo
any particular step if I just cancel
this then I'm back to this if I cancel
this I'm back to my original form so you
can anytime undo your changes and you
can basically work on this so we are
working on this particular column now
there are various other options that you
can look at so for example these are
this is some of my data but it does not
have much information it would be good
to load some bigger data set and then
use these Transformations or basically
working on changing the data types as I
mentioned or if you would want to do a
filtering and remove certain fields and
only select particular Fields if that's
what you're interested doing a right
click where I want to create a copy of
this and then basically I can
use that particular copy now what I can
also do is I can add column from
examples I can duplicate column and then
I can make some changes to that so this
is my duplicate column and say for
example you would want uh this one to be
changed so we can say remove duplicates
we can basically if you are doing some
kind of change you want to change the
format here you can do that you can use
for other things like filling up and all
that now I can just call it rename and
let's say
um Alias scientist name right and I can
continue adding columns or I can do some
Transformations and once you have done
with these transactions now this one if
you see it shows as integer but is it an
integer no this is an date format so I
can go for modeling and change the
formats what I can also do is I can
select this and it says it's not a
decimal it's not a fixed decimal it is
date time it is date it is date time and
time zone
right and you can select any one of
these so for example let's make it date
which makes it more meaningful but then
what happens is when you do this it is
going for the default dates or the older
dates so I don't like that so what we
will have to do is we will have to
basically transform this and here we
have transform you have change type so
you have date and time you have date you
have time so let's choose date and time
and if you see here it gives me some
default timing based on these values
which we do not like so again filter it
out but what we can do is we can just
make sure that this is changed or you
want to make it a string because we are
not going to do any computation here so
I can keep it as date but then if I have
more Fields like month and days and so
on then you can do that so here it also
has
the option so when you have selected
this you have an option called transform
and transpose sorry transform also has
various options which allow you to work
on these do you want to do some
scientific calculations do you want to
work on
the date field so as of now it is just
integer so we can use one of these we
can do a group by but obviously we don't
have much data here so as of now let us
retain this I can just change this to
text and that's okay because we are
going to look at this later we can add
more data and work on it so as of now
once we have done all these changes you
can go back to say home and here you
have close and apply and I can basically
say close and apply so the changes will
be applied and then my new table which
we just created by entering some random
data performing some basic
transformations
will be available so if you look into
this one
so that's where my data is it shows me
the columns but there is no aggregated
column as such here you don't see any
summation Mark you just see the field
names or the column names you see the
values now obviously if you go into
modeling there is no
or there is no existence of a different
table which you can join these tables or
you can perform some transactions come
back to the data set so this looks good
and we have it here now obviously we
have not created any visualization based
on this which we can and we can continue
working on it so here this is my data
set which is a small table where we have
created some data and we can use it
anytime now let's work on a bigger data
set and see what kind of Transformations
we can do we can then also see on
modeling or basically using some smarter
ways of working with the data
so what we would want to do is we would
want to load some data here so let's go
into
sorry let's go into home let's go to get
data let's use our old store data and
I'm going to take the global Superstore
which is huge data set with all the
countries and the products and the sales
which have happened and we can take this
data but before loading it as I
suggested earlier we should basically
transform the data we should basically
transform the data so that you don't end
up loading everything and you don't work
on all the data I mean unless you really
want to so here I will this Excel sheet
which I'm talking about has two
different tabs we have used it before so
let's use orders let's use returns and
that basically shows me the data what we
have so I can do a load but that's not
what we would want to do so you can do a
load and you can get all the data but
let's go to transform
make some basic Transformations before
we load the data so our power bi editor
allows us to work on this now here we
have
it says this preview may be up to nine
days old so I can do a refresh I can
select this and I say first thing is use
first row as header because that's what
I want so it is basically
setting the first row as header which
looks good and we have some order IDs we
have the
returned If the product was returned so
let's look at the filter here so it just
has yes values which we are looking at
so
it says list may be incomplete let's say
load more
and let's see what are the filters here
so either there might be a product which
is returned or it might be blank field
so that is chosen so that's fine we have
order ID we have region which is
basically showing me different regions
here let's look at orders and orders is
again having your row ID order ID order
date ship date ship mode so you have
quite large amount of data here for your
different countries now in earlier
example I chose United States and then I
was only focusing on the states and city
in United States so we can do that now
I can basically work on refresh so
whatever preview was stored in the
memory we are just refreshing it now
here we have this row ID and if you see
the row ID is an integer obviously we
will not be performing any kind of
computation here so here
you don't have any row ID but here we
have row ID so let's make it uh from
integer let's make it string and I'll
say replace current so that's that looks
fine it's a row ID which we will use to
search but we are not going to perform
any computations unless you want to find
on an average on row ID or anything else
now you have order IDs so what we can do
is we can filter some values
we can rename the field as we desired
right so for example let's go in here
and what we can do is let's go into
a customer ID ship
okay and here you have say State you
have region
okay now at any point of time if I would
want to filter out the values the easier
option is that you can select on this
one and here you can do some text
filtering okay or you can basically
select the values from here so for
example if I say let's get rid of select
all what we will be interested in say
United States and UK that's the data we
want and then I can basically say okay
so it is basically going to filter out
the data which is for United States and
UK as of now now what we can also do is
how about doing some more filtering
before we basically work on this so
let's go in here and we are looking at
United States and UK related data and
let's look at
it is sometimes good that you can
basically
work on the data here so for example I
go into orders now what I would want to
do is I would want to look at
the fields okay and we want to we have
not yet loaded the data so if you look
in the background I just have my
scientists because we have not applied
these changes we have not loaded we are
still in the transformation stage right
now what we can do is let's go for so we
can do segment and all these kind of
fields so can be used for grouping the
data so we will see that whenever you
have a data set you would already know
there are certain fields which have
repeated values which can be used to
group the data and we can do that we can
change any kind of values which are not
going to be computed on so for example I
have postal code I can use this but
again we are not going to find a postal
code which is greater than something
right so integer is not the valid type
let's change it to text okay and if for
example I would want to look at this so
I have done some
changes here
okay and this shows me null so for
example let me just revert this back and
let's make it
a whole number
okay so there are certain columns or
rows which do not have some values and
we can basically get rid of those values
so as of now we can do a filtering here
so let's keep the postal code AS integer
or let's
change it to text do a replace
content and now what we will do is we'll
scroll all the way right might be I'm
interested in technology category so
that's what I'm interested in so what I
can do is here I can do some filtering
so I can basically choose
technology now the easier way would be
since these are categories and there are
only three categories we really don't
want to go and apply text filters here
but if you had something like an office
supply and Office Inventory then you
could have done some text filters so
let's not do some text filtering here
what we can do is I would be interested
in technology so that's the field I'm
interested in so now you are only having
data which is related to technology
okay and you have some product names so
this is where we want to do some kind of
filtering so
we can rename the field we can select
some Fields so let's for example let's
go for
um
any of the field which I think might
have more entries here so for example
let's go for
Canon Wireless or Canon Image right so
let's go for product names and I will
say let's
go here
now I could have done a transformation
but that's not what we want we want to
do some it filtering so let's go to text
filter and here I can say begins with I
can say ends with I can say contains so
let's go for contains
and it says enter the value here so you
would want to keep the rows where the
product name contains something and it
gives you some suggestion
right so where you are seeing in some
values here so for example if I would
have selected this then it applies the
complete thing but that's not what I
want so I will get rid of all this and I
will say it contains Canon now I can go
for advanced filtering also okay wherein
you can select Advanced and then you can
give different columns and
what do they contain
what kind of values you are looking for
so you can do that but we will not go
for advanced in one step let's go for
basic and let's say okay
and now I should get all the products
which are Canon and you have different
products so this is one kind of
filtering I've done it tells me what is
the category of this it is machines it
is copiers it is obviously belonging to
the technology category we are looking
at uh the market which is for this
particular data when you look at the
country we are still focusing on United
States and United Kingdom that kind of
data right so we have filtered the data
we have done some uh selection based on
the data here and what I can do is I can
then
basically rename a particular field so I
can do that I can say I'm interested in
uh
um sales which is the data here we can
basically look into the quantity so
sales is something which we are
interested in but might be we are
interested in sales which are more than
a particular value I'm not interested in
lower amount of sales I would want to
look into United States and UK data but
I am interested in sales or I'm looking
at if the discount percentage was
something or if the profit was more
right so we can apply different kind of
values here but what we can do is with
these changes because you don't want to
transform and make changes all here
you want to make the changes once the
data set is uploaded so we have selected
some data we have create done some
Transformations we can basically break a
particular column into multiple columns
if that's what we want if we see that we
will do an aggregation based on year or
we will do a aggregation based on the
country or year and Order ID right so we
can break this data into multiple
columns so we can do that but for now
let's do a close and apply
and
let's apply this so that's going to
apply all these changes it's going to
load my data but remember now we are
having selective or selected data which
gets loaded so that should get be
available here so it takes time
sometimes so you have to wait and then
you can go ahead and check here so for
example now I'm looking in tables let's
basically minimize this let's go for
orders and this is the data I have which
obviously row ID if you see so you have
all the row IDs and again again you can
do filtering here but this is where you
have already loaded the data the data is
available and then you can start working
on the columns here so we have this if
you closely see we see this summation
Mark and this basically means that these
are my aggregated columns or these
values are measures which can be used
for calculations so we can see that we
can create on our own aggregations so we
can do that we can rename the field as
we have seen
we can filter out the data so we have
all the fields showing up from orders
and let's also look at the returns
which basically has the columns the
order ID and your region so it basically
shows the region here where was the
product returned from and we have this
information so what we are doing is we
when we were doing a text filter in the
previous example
remember it was case sensitive
okay and you have to take care of when
you're doing a text filter you have to
give a field which exactly matches as it
exists in the content now okay this is
the data we have and let's look at the
order column right now what we can do is
we can do some quick Transformations
here and we can basically look for
more data here so
let's say we have some filtering to be
done now I can do a filtering based on
my uh uh products
so we had all these products but now
let's do a filtering on product and then
products you have copiers you have
machines so you have mainly two
categories right and when you look at
machines it basically talks about your
PC
uh something so let's look for machines
and here we have basically The copier
fields which are more
so I can basically
go for filtering here
and that's the data we have so we don't
want to really unselect any of these
here but what I'm doing is I'm saying
text filter and let's go into this one
now and let's say contains
okay so I'm saying contains and then I
can basically say let's say copier
now that's what I'm interested in
and
so rows where product name contains
copier
okay now you can give a and condition
here so if you would want a specific
copier if you are interested in okay
let's also say
contains and let's go for laser also
laser and let's say okay
so you see the data gets filtered out
here and we have the sales which we are
seeing here so let's go to sales and we
will be interested in anything above 500
so let's go to sales
let's go for number filters let's say
greater than
and I will say for example 500 oh sorry
okay and
let's say okay so that basically filters
out the data and then I am also
interested in quantity Where I would
want the quantity to be
more than one or more than two so for
example so let's go in
here and you can basically choose what
is the filter you want so you can apply
any number of filters now you have the
filtering here you can always click on
the filter and if you want you can just
do a clear filter and the filtering will
be gone so you have all the data right
and
this is the particular data we have and
here I have say for example
product name now I can keep the filter
because I am interested only in these
values or I can filter out so this tells
me that when we did a and it is
basically going for laser and copier
right so let's say for example clear all
filters the thing is gone what we can do
is let's go here go for text filters say
contains and here I will say it can be a
copier okay or
so last time we did an end and I'll do
it contains laser
so
let's choose this that gives me more
entries so either the product name has
copier or it has laser it has the
quantity it has the product name and we
have all this detail here now what we
can also do is we can do some
transformation on the product ID so for
example you have product ID or order ID
so order ID shows up as looks like the
country name uh the year and then the
order ID so we can basically split it up
so I can select this and here I have
option of
let's go to home so when you have you
have selected this column so you have an
option of transform data here so use the
power query Editor to connect prepare
and transform the data so if you really
want to transform the data here if I
basically select this
if I just right click here
now here it just tells me do you want a
new column do you want to create a copy
of this column okay you want to create
copy table so this is your transformed
data what you have and for example let's
create a copy table
and let's come in here
so you should be able to see your
copy table now so let's go in
and select this one
and what you need to do here is creating
a copy of this or copy table would not
be the right option what we can do is we
can work on transforming this rather
than doing it from here so you have this
option of adding a new column going for
a new measure renaming it right so
that's
okay but what we can do is Select this
particular column let's do a home and
first thing is let's go to transform so
I want to transform the data now let's
select this one and it brings up your
power editor again here we were
interested in orders so we are looking
at our data here
now if you see my country's United
States and UK so you can confirm that if
you look at category it is technology
product name has copier and Laser as we
selected so those things are retained so
you have not lost any changes as of now
so this order ID column what we have now
as I said you can be doing a filtering
okay you can select this particular
column and then you have other things
which can be used to transform here like
you want to change the data type you
want to use first OS header you want to
replace some values okay you want to run
some merge queries you want to do some
analytics so all these options are here
now what we can do is while this column
is selected I can do a right click now
there is an option called transform
which is basically going to help me in
changing the data here okay now I can
basically duplicate the column so I
really don't want to work on this column
itself but it would be good to have
a duplicate column on which we can work
on so I can do a split column here if I
would want to but let's create a
duplicate column so let's say duplicate
column
now that gives me a duplicate column so
we can rename it later so now I will not
work on my original column but I'll work
on a duplicate column and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to basically
transform or split this so again where I
click now you have a split buy so we can
say split by by delimiter or by number
or by characters or by position so by
lowercase and uppercase so you can do
all of this so let's go for by delimiter
now if you see it basically identifies
the delimiter which is hyphen or Dash
now you can go for split at left most
identify right sorry left most
delimiters right most each occurrence of
delimiter and that's what we want to do
you can look into advanced options where
it says split into columns
so do you want to split that into
columns do you want to split that into
rows because that's more or less like
doing a group by and you can say number
of columns to split into so we have here
one two three four values so that looks
good to me and let's do say for example
if I choose three
so I can choose 3 and then split using
special characters so you could do that
so let's for example let's say okay
and let's look at the data how it looks
like we can anytime delete the data we
can keep it the way we want right so
what we did was
we created a copy of the column then we
did a split
and what we have seen is we just have
three columns now if you see the fourth
bit is gone fourth bit doesn't show up
right because I just did a 3 as the
resulting column so I have the order ID
okay and we can check if there is
already an order ID column so we have
order ID but that has the complete order
ID year and the relatively product ID so
you can see the customer ID you can look
at this one so it basically has your
order ID and then let's look at the
fields here so we have the product ID
which says t e c m a I'm looking at the
first one three seven zero zero and
that has in no relation to the order ID
right so we can make sure that there is
nothing which is conflicting with our
entries now once that is done so we have
order ID which can be used to categorize
the data you have order ID which is
basically the year okay and you have
order ID which is basically having some
more value now I can keep this data as I
want so I can basically click on this I
can go for renaming and I can say let's
say let's call it
order
ID
and let's say
IDs so let us in case there is a
particular column and you would want to
look at so
just give the name correctly now order
IDs is find so here we will also rename
this one so let's call it
uh order
here
and that's going to be ordered here so
we can again change this to string
okay and here you have the order ID so
let's rename this one
and I have my
let's call order
number
right so we have we are seeing all the
steps which we have added here we just
split the data based on the delimiter
and we have now three new columns which
have got added to our existing data
which was already filtered and we have
done some
splitting up of data by creating a
duplicate and then renaming it right so
if you
go and look at your Transformations now
if I would have done a split here
straight away then my original column
would be gone but probably we want the
original column because sometimes you
may want to search order ID which I
Consolidated information sometimes you
may want to segregate it based on year
right now we have the year field or
order date field here you have the ship
date right but then might be you want to
just aggregate based on year you don't
want to really spend time in aggregating
or extracting the month and day and so
on so my these three columns can be
useful now what I can also do is I can
merge The Columns if I want so we have
split the columns but what I can do is I
can say select select select
so using your control and now do a right
click so you should have an option
called merge columns right now this is
something which is we would want to
merge so let's say merge columns and
let's say do you want to keep a
separator so yes I want to keep a
separator but might be this time I will
give my separator is a uh colon and then
what is the merge column name you want
to create so let's call it something
like
um
order
okay
uh year and then let's call it num right
so sometimes renaming the fields to a
name which makes more sense or based on
your naming convention is good so let's
do a merge and now what I have done is I
have done merging of those columns so
I split the data I merge The Columns and
now if you see my
The Columns which I had created those
columns are gone because you did a merge
you didn't merge and now you have the
fields which are either
uh earlier you had
something which is separated by a
hyphen and here you have something which
is separated by colon right now anytime
if you want you can
unmerge this by removing this step right
and you can get rid of this merge column
so if for example I would do that
so
I have my data back right I have my data
back so what we could have done is we
can select this
okay and then what we can do is like
what we did earlier so you can
basically go for
removing the columns okay you can do a
merge column okay you can select one by
one and create duplicate of those and
then you can merge them right so all the
possible options are there so you can
the best option would be to create a
duplicate of these columns and then
basically merge them as per your
convenience so maybe you can say order
IDs and order number is the pairing what
you want here is something which you
don't want right because we already have
the date field so I can basically say
remove
foreign
and this one is gone now I will select
this and this and let's go for merge
columns and I want to give a separator
which is
might be without the ear and you have
space or you can go for custom like
earlier we had give a symbol and then
what do you want to call it so let's say
order
specs
okay
right so this makes more meanings
because we already have the date field
so why do I want the year into my order
ID so I can always be doing a
segregation now based on order specs
right now this is some simple
Transformations what we are doing here
we are seeing the data which we have
okay now what I can do is I can
basically first apply these changes
so that all my changes what I have done
are applied right now once these changes
are done we can basically go ahead and
save this file so I can just say save I
can go for save as I have different
other options so
if you would want to perform keep
performing your transformation then you
can just do this you can add a column
you can view the data so for now our
Transformations are good enough and what
we can do is we can basically
go back to home we can do a close and
apply and we will be back to
our data set which has been modified so
we can see if the data what we have has
been transformed
so we have order specs here that's good
we did not do any filtering or
we have the filters left here which
basically tells me that there are these
different fields we have not removed
them but what we are doing is we are
just applying a filter to choose copiers
and Laser Printers
so that's what we have here and this is
good enough now what I can do is once
this is done I can basically save it
so I would want to call it some kind of
report if you would want to create okay
so let's call it
as uh let's say second
report
and here I will say
country
and Technology
specific info
let's save it
and now basically I have saved my data
so what you can do is you can go for
creating other report or basically
having this information published if
that's what you want to do if you want
to go for visualization because right
now what we are seeing is we have a lot
of data here we have a lot of data here
it shows me there are these uh tables or
data sets which we have worked on that
shows me
here in the models but there is no
relationship with them if you're going
to visualization then you don't have any
option or you have not created any
visualizations based on this data but if
you go here now based on the data what
we transformed if you see we have order
specs
right now that's what we chose we
basically have other fields so you have
ship date you have aggregated columns
which can be used for visualizing and we
can work on this so I can come back here
and what I would be interested in is
this data set is fine but I want to do
some grouping I want to basically have
some selective data in this and for that
what I can do is let's go for ship mode
now this is something what we have so we
are in this data field
now we have this transform so let's go
back to transform again
and let's choose our orders so that's
the data we have and now if you see here
this is
you know huge amount of data what we
want is we want to group them based on
the shipping mode
so here you have an option called Group
by so I can select this I can go in here
I can basically work on okay get rid of
duplicate values but that's not what we
want to do you want to do a group by so
as I said you can do a group by from
here or you can choose from the
transform option above and you can do a
group buy so let's do a group by
now
how do you want to group the data so I'm
saying I want to group the data here
based on shipping mode
or
which is the other column you want to
use to do a group by so let's go for
shipping mode and what is the new column
name right so we want to basically find
out
that you want to go for ship mode but
that's not enough I mean I can do a ship
mode and I can do a grouping by but you
want to just count the rows no that's
not what we want to do so let's go to
Advanced so ship mode is fine so that's
your grouping right but then what we
also want to do is we want to do a
grouping based on
say sales so here for example let's go
for sales
okay and what should we call this so
maybe we can say uh shipment
wise sales whatever you would want to
call so you can basically get the
operation do you want to really count
the rows no we want to basically do a
summing or we want to might be find out
an average price right so let's do a sum
okay and here I would want to do a
summing based on
say for example sales so this is what
I'm going to use for getting a count of
the sales now grouping by might be we
will change this instead of
[Music]
instead of sales we are using a ship
mode what we can also do is let's go for
a segment
and that would be valid grouping so it
will take a combination of ship mode
segmenting group the data based on that
and then get me the sales which is
which is basically let's call it
shipment wise sales
so it gets a sum so let's do a okay
and that's my more relevant data which
I'm looking at so I'm looking at the
ship mode I'm looking at what is the
segment and then I'm looking at what is
the total sales there I'm looking at
again the ship mode standard and home
office so always remember when you are
choosing multiple fields or multiple
columns for grouping by you are
basically having
a combination of two Fields so that has
to be unique and your grouping is done
based on that so now you are looking at
the sales wise and this is something as
an important information what we have so
we have done some transformation and
what you can do is
you can use other ways like you can use
pivot to get individual values from it
you can run on merge queries which is
basically running some merge queries and
merge the query with another query in
this workbook if you have so you can go
for this now I can basically go for
apply and close so just to add to the
group by step what we did was if you see
here I have removed the group by filter
which we just did couple of minutes back
and what I have done is instead of
transforming your complete data set you
can basically create a copy of it so for
example I can just do a copy and then I
can come here and do a paste and I have
done that and I'm calling it order
summarized but this is my complete data
now what we will do here is we will
basically go ahead and do a grouping by
again like what we did earlier based on
your shipment based on your segment and
based on the sales so that's what we are
looking for so let's go for the ship
mode and
we go for group by
and here you would want to go for
advanced to ship mode and this one I
will go for Segment so that's fine now
we want the new column name so let's say
shipment
wise sales
so I want to do a summing not the
counting of rows and I want to do a
summation based on sales like what we
did earlier and then you say okay
and that basically gives you the data
here now
what we have is we have the resultant
data based on the data which is coming
in from here we did the same thing just
one minute back but we worked on the
original data set so what I did was I
created a copy and now I'm working on
this one so I'll say close and apply
and now we are back to our desktop so it
is applying these changes where we have
done some Transformations we have done
some grouping by
and what we can do is
once we have the data here we get
anytime look at our data sets or tables
so this is my original one if you see
now I have order summarized I can just
pull out this information I basically
have my returns which we have not really
touched and we have the scientists so we
have all the four data sets here now
what we can also do is let's look into
order summarized and we just have this
data here so this is fine and you can
continue working on this you can
basically merge columns from two
different data sets and then you can get
the merged column
and you can rename it so you can
obviously do that you can basically do a
uncheck
whenever you're working on these data
sets so what you can do is
if you would want to work on
transforming for example let's go back
here
and say I want to do some transformation
on it so how did we do it we just did a
transform
and you can go back to transform so you
have this data here and
the data what you have you might be
interested in transforming this into
something else and then you don't want
to maybe load this data so you have this
option where you are selecting orders
and then you have something called as
enable load which can be unchecked so
when you do a uncheck what will happen
is whatever changes you perform only
those changes related data set will be
loaded and they will still be available
but this will not affect your
it will not affect your original one so
for example let's say copy and let's go
in here I will do a paste let's say
orders
oh I did a paste I need to rename this
so let's do renaming let's say orders
and here I will say summarized
and I will say us
so I'm renaming it now let that get
loaded we can perform some
Transformations on it so I have here
where's my country so let's look for
country
yeah
and let's look for Country so here I
will go for only United States
okay that's what I'm interested in and
then I can choose well I am interested
in just Central us so I can basically go
for just the central us and I can get
rid of all of these
so now I should have only Central us
data and this is fine and this is the
data might be we are focusing on right
now for doing some visualization might
be looking at sales might be looking at
the product name so you have the product
name now remember you don't see any
filters here right because the filters
are coming from the resultant set and
your transformation so if you have any
filters you would be seeing in the top
row now this is the data we have let's
uh let's not restrict it to region
region would then reduce my data but
that's good enough for us I can just say
no I'm clearing off this filter I'm
still looking at United States but I
want to look at all the regions yeah
whatever we would be interested in
category and that's anyways chosen as
technology which we had chosen when we
were loading the data we have copies and
machines right and we can basically keep
this now this is fine I can apply the
changes
I can apply the changes based on this
one
and what I can do is I can just say for
now apply
so that's going to apply all the changes
which you have done in orders or summary
or the new one right and what I can do
is now I can choose order and I can say
don't enable this in load
so it says disabling load will remove
the table from the report and any
visuals that use its columns will be
broken we are not creating any visuals
as of now the table will be removed so
that's fine
and now I will say close and apply
so what happens is you are loading the
data based on the changes okay now you
have your
order summarized you have returns you
have scientist but you basically do not
have orders anymore so that was not
loaded so I only have this one I only
have this one and
you have returns you have scientists you
don't have the orders column right now
that particular data set was not loaded
at all because we did not choose that to
be loaded right now while I'm in this
orders which is
let's see here and actually you can drag
in yeah so you have order summary and
this has basically kind of data which
I'm looking for so I really don't need
the orders table so you can do it in
steps and you can aggregate this you can
have aggregated data you can have all
the data which is filtered transformed
grouped by and then basically just load
it and the original data set which you
used that's no more being loaded here
now at any point of time if I really
want
I can go back to transform data and
remember it is still here it is still
here it's not gone right so you can
basically select this and you can say
enable load and you will have the data
back which you can continue working on
right so these are some quick
Transformations which really help us in
working on the data now obviously if you
have data you want to perform some left
joins right joins you have inner joints
outer joints so you can always do that
you can take two different data sets
might be I'm interested in taking the
orders summarized which talks about
standard class consumer shipment wise
sales and here if I look at order
summary I have other details but the
thing is we need to make sure that these
have the values
these have the values say for example
the segment column here and the segment
column here can really be used to join
these two tables so if I create a
relationship or if I create a join I can
basically merge the data so this is how
you work on data we will also see some
more examples on might be modeling the
data using some Expressions to work on
the data so we already looked at
creating a report
selecting particular fields and then
publishing the report onto your power bi
service now this is the report which we
had created which says State order ID
sales and then I also added this
returned field and that was basically by
creating a relationship between order
and returns which we can also have a
look in model so this is the
relationship which is created if you
just place your cursor here it tells me
that we have a relationship between
order ID of returns and Order ID of
orders and that basically allows me to
join the data bring it in my one report
now this is basically your data sources
you can look at and if you click on your
visualization so that shows you your
report now what we can also do is we can
make it interesting now we would not
want to scroll through the fields to see
wherever or what was the order or what
was the order I ID which was returned
now I can do a sorting I can filter out
what I can also do is I can use this
option which shows slicer here and that
basically allows me to work with this
data so we have this report here and
basically as I said you can click in
here it shows the data now what I can do
is I would want to filter out
information or slice the information
using your returned either being yes or
having a field which has no value how do
we do that so basically I can drag and
drop the returned
here as a field which comes from returns
now that basically shows me only the
value as yes but I do know that there is
there are some fields which are blank
now how do I add filter to this so I can
click on this one and then I can click
on slicer now once that does so it
basically pulls out all the different
values so you have either yes or you
have the blank field for returned so
what we can do is we can select yes you
will see only
the orders and their IDs and sales where
the products were returned so that gives
me hundred eight thousand one one eight
and I can select blank so that will
basically get me all the orders or
products which were not returned now
this is a simple way wherein I can add a
filter to or a slicer to my report to
basically give viewers a choice of uh
selecting different fields and you can
add any number of slicers you can
basically say I would want particular
kind of information so for example if I
go into orders and we know we have the
state now I do have the state
information here and basically I can if
I would be interested I could filter
this out in my report itself I can sort
it I can look it in a different order
what I can also do is how about bringing
in state here and basically dragging it
here so that gives me the state option
it is giving me a visual which is
basically giving me a geographic
location of all these points so yes that
can be good what I can also do is I can
keep this which basically shows me the
state map might be it can be useful you
can zoom in you can zoom out you can
look at specific information here you
can drag and drop here so that's fine
what I can also do is I can again take
the state and bring it here
and that basically can be instead of my
map I can go for slicer so that gives me
all the values here and which basically
allows users to choose the fields or the
states which you would be interested in
looking at so for example if somebody is
interested in looking at the data for
Georgia just select this one and you see
the map automatically shows you where in
the map that's the place and it shows me
all the sales for Georgia State now I
can also basically select yes and that
shows me which were the orders which
were basically returned so that gives me
a quick overview of statewise what is
the geographical location if the orders
were returned or maybe I can just click
on blank and it shows me the
non-returned orders I can again go here
and uncheck the Georgie option and that
shows me all the states now once you
have done this this looks like a
comprehensive report which can be useful
for the viewers for your management team
and so on so we can just do a save and
that basically is saving my report so I
have this report now what if I publish
this report so I can just do a publish
and when I publish it says okay
workspace so let's say select
and then it says replacing this data set
may impact two reports you already have
a data set named by this one view the
impact I would say replace or I will say
view impact so that basically takes me
to the power bi service because
sometimes we may have some reports which
we have already uploaded and updating an
existing report might basically affect
my existing report so it basically shows
me the impact analysis it shows me one
workspace there are two reports they are
they have not been added to dashboard
but these are the ones which will get
modified so let's for example as of now
go ahead here and let's look into my
power bi so go back to your desktop and
I'll say no I don't want to replace so
click on cancel so I do not want to
publish it or it might be what I can do
is I can try saving it as a different
report so let's say save as
and now I will basically say
additional
filters
okay let's save it
so now you see the name on the top
changes to additional filters and now
it's saved to publish this and now I can
go ahead and publish it select your
workspace
and basically it says this is the report
being published with our additional
filters with a map which gives a
geographical uh area showing us the
information and then basically what I
can do is once it is done I can look
into my power bi service like we did
earlier you can do a filtering we can
basically query this data we can share
it with other users who might be
interested in looking at this particular
data now this says it is done so it says
get quick insights and maybe it's a good
an option to look into what kind of
insights it's it gives you so click on
that see the beauty of power bi where it
tries to search for any kind of insights
which it can gather from the kind of
report which you have built
now once the insights are ready it will
let you know what we can also do is we
can come in here click on
view data set
so you see now it shows your additional
filters and here you have option where
it should be showing your report so
let's say View and view is fine so
and if it doesn't show up sometimes it
might be taking taking time for
refreshing so you can always go here and
then you can click on your report
and that should get populated
so this is the report these are the
filters which I have gives me an option
of choosing all the states and basically
allows me to edit the report and look at
all the information here meanwhile we
can see here it is still trying to
gather some insights from the data and
now you see there are some insights here
so it says sales which is coming up and
a subset of your data was analyzed and
the following insights were found so
you're looking at sales by ship mode so
it says standard class second class
first class and same day so there were
different shipping modes in our data and
that's what it shows me the sales which
one had the majority it shows me the
profit so which city or state had more
profit so New York City has noticeable
more profits here average by shipping
cost by sub categories so there are
these different subcategories which we
can look at such as copiers and machines
have noticeably more shipping cost
profit by product name
and you can basically look at the row ID
and quantity so this is where you're
looking at a regression analysis you're
looking at row ID and quantity so there
is a correlation between row ID and
quantity so these are two different
variables or fields which are related
you're looking row ID by category
the row ID so it says California has
noticeably more row IDs sales your
profit count of region and count of
returns so there is a correlation again
between two different variables average
of shipping costs now we would have
taken a lot of time building all these
visualizations but Power bi has already
helped you in gathering all these
insights and then you can basically
select which one of these is what you
are interested in you can focus and look
for more information based on all the
fields it has given you good amount of
insights which will help anyone who is
looking at this particular report so
that's your quick insights here and we
have this information
now once you have this information this
is basically where you have your focus
mode so it says subset of your data was
analyzed following insights were found
you can
basically say download
and here you have other options which
allow you to work with your power bi so
let's look at this one so this is where
we have our report and we can continue
exploring it more
one more interesting feature which power
bi has other than having your insights
ready to use which is basically in your
workspace and you can basically use
these insights what we are looking at
various options here
and basically you have this option where
it says spin the visual if you are
interested in a particular Insight you
can always pin it which you can always
go back and look into what you can also
do is you can also click on edit report
here now that's a report which has
already been published
to your power bi service not yet shared
but that can be shared or that can be
subscribed now once you click on edit
report it has option of reading View
mobile layout you have basically an
option which says basically options for
navigating through the data set you can
go for how visuals on the canvas
interact with each other
you have all these options and one of
the good options is ask a question so
you can always click on ask a question
and that basically says
some suggestions now you can open this
and it says okay ask a question about
your data try one of these to get
started what is the average sale sort
orders by order date sort orders by
product ID how many ship modes are there
compare quantity and discount so do not
worry that your report has
only four Fields so it has State order
ID sales and returned with some filters
but what about you looking at how many
ship modes are there so it is already
looking at your data so if you click on
this one here and you can see what are
the different fields what we have and
you have ship date and ship mode so this
is one of the fields which it is showing
you to ask a question now what you can
do is you can say how many ship modes
are there let's click on that let's ask
this question it says four ship modes
and do you want to add this to report
yes you can you can let it be as it is
so you can basically keep this question
here and here you have an option the
visual is showing number of ship modes
when you place your cursor here if you
see here turn this q a result into a
standard Visual and let's do that and
basically it is saying number of ship
modes
right so now that's the power of your bi
power bi which has basically allowed you
to ask a question and quickly add a
visual to your report now what we can do
is we can basically save this or you can
say save as and give any different name
so might be I'll just say save because I
would want to have this information and
the report is saved so in this way you
can basically not only create smart
visuals you can not only relate
different data sources using data models
or relationships you can add maps you
can add filters you can add quick
questions you can basically just go here
and say for example you would want to
ask a different question now we see the
fields here how about looking at the
shipping cost right so here I can say
um
what is the
uh highest shipping
cost and that shows me some suggestions
let's select that and that shows me the
value
which is great and I can keep it as it
is I can basically convert this to a
visual I may want to keep the question
because might be this question was asked
and you would want to see the result
here might be you can move this
somewhere here
and that gives me some kind of question
which was asked and we can do a save
and that's my report which has been
saved in my bi service the data set is
still there you can basically go ahead
and share this
now when we talk about data modeling one
of the things which we are importantly
talking about is the relationships now
when you talk about your a relational
database World in simple terms what we
can understand is that you normally when
you talk about data modeling you have a
facts table and you have a dimension
table
so let's quickly understand what you
mean by your fact table or what we talk
about table which has measures or which
can be your calculated values and then
you also have your dimension tables
which are holding your data so for
example you have a dimension table now
we can understand that with simple
examples so this Dimension table might
have say
five columns let's take a simple example
so let's say we have a customer ID we
have the name we have the location of
the customer what products the customer
bought and the country of the customer
so here you can say the customer ID that
would be the primary key column which is
basically uniquely identifies the data
here and this is what I'm talking about
as a dimension table now I can have then
specific data for product table so that
would basically have more information or
specific information about different
products so here do we have the products
which are in the customer table which
basically talks about what are the
products the customer bought and here I
can basically have a product ID so
that's the primary key column for this
table and then you have your product
description which is basically the
product name and then you can say the
product quality high quality low quality
and probably the price of the product so
this is one more Dimension table now you
could have another dimension tables
which could have a link to this table so
when we talk about your schema and if we
want to understand data modeling so
there is what we call as you your
snowflake schema and your star schema so
when I say star schema in simple words
it could be understood that you could
have multiple Dimension tables in this
way and then you have a fact stable
which basically has information so I
could say there is a customer ID here
you have your product ID here might be
you have something else which talks
about location ID if you have a specific
table for the location which is based on
Country so you have location ID and then
the country name if that's one table so
you have location ID and then you can
have some measures or columns which are
nothing but calculated values so when I
say calculated values might be it is
quantity might be it is tax amount and
so on so you have basically
relationships so this is your primary
key and you have one relationship here
you have product ID you have one
relationship here you have location ID
you have one relationship here and
probably this one also relates to a
particular column which has a relation
so this becomes your fact table and
these are your dimension tables and
that's what we mean by your star schema
in simple terms where you have a direct
relationship between the dimension
tables which basically contain the data
and your facts table which contains the
measures now Dimension data can have lot
of values which could be unique or could
be duplicates now that could again have
your facts table facts table could have
repeated values so you could have
product ID and location ID and same
product and location ID but maybe that
belongs to a different customer ID so
you can have different entries so that's
yours start schema now if you talk about
the other kind of schema then that is
your Snowflake and snowflake basically
means that you have another dimension
table but that is not having a direct
connection with fact table so for
example here I'm talking about products
and then this particular product is
related to a product subcategory so
maybe I have one more column here which
talks about subcategory of the products
and here you have the table which has
sub category ID and then you have
basically details of that particular
product might be it is a luxury product
might be it is a consumer product or
whatever it is so always when you have
the main key so these becomes your
primary key and here you are talking
about your foreign key concept or say
for example you have these as your
foreign keys because this one or your
product ID is basically your primary key
so you could have these columns which
can be taken so if you have in simple
terms either you have a star schema or
you have a snowflake schema wherein your
dimension tables are then connected to
other dimension tables but some
Dimension tables have no connection
between fact and dimension so if you are
pulling out information which is about a
product and a subcategory of that then
you would have to connect your fact
table with Dimension table so this is in
short
brief about your data modeling which we
need to understand when we are defining
relationships now we can have our data
sets which can be coming in from
different sources we want to connect
them so that we can access the data from
both of them and then we can basically
have a Consolidated information so what
we can do here is let's look at an
example
so other than our regular data let's
load some interesting data now here I
have a scenario where I was using a
different tool but then we are
investigating or we are doing some
threat hunting now you have the data
which comes in from different sources so
let me just show you that so for example
if I look into
the data here and this data set or these
set of data sets I'll show you the
GitHub link from where you can download
all this data set you have to just go
ahead and type say bot sv1 data set and
you have basically the full data set
which can be downloaded which is huge or
you have the attack only data set now
this has basically your windows event
logs it has firewall related events it
has DNS or HTTP and you have other data
here so this data can also be used to
basically join your different data sets
and create a relationship because what
we know is the data might be coming in
from different sources but then it has
certain fields which have a connectivity
between them so we can use one such data
set or couple of data sets so if you
would want to download this you can
directly download these attack only data
sets or what you can do is all these
source files are available as Json or
also as CSV Source type that's where I
got the data from so you can use this so
for example if we have the data coming
in here and say I have data coming in
from firewall that is 40 gate you have
data coming in from HTTP stream or HTTP
DNS you have Windows Event log and we
can take up these data sets and see how
we can basically use them now say for
example you are searching for the HTTP
data and then you would want to find out
how many Source IPS are there or how
many destination IPS are there and then
what kind of information it contains so
let's start with some data set here so
for example let's say get data
I will use Excel I will get into the
data types I can choose all files and
let's go for the first one just to play
around with this one let's see what does
this contain now this is a huge data set
48 event that's mainly for firewall
related data so let's open this now
obviously the data is huge it shows
whatever we have based on first 200 rows
which we see there is a serial number
there is a Time Source uh what is the
protocol which was used what's the
source type you have host you have index
you have Splunk server and then you have
the raw events which are all in one
column which obviously we can split and
create different columns based on our
requirement so before we do a load of
this data let's go for transformation
which brings our power query editor now
we have the serial number are we really
interested in this so I would say
probably not so I will just go ahead and
remove this column so time is fine you
have time which can be then split as per
time zone you have Source you have
Source type which we know it is coming
from fortigate event I can keep that
just in case I would later want the
information to be understood I have host
I have index now this is where the data
is coming from and I don't need this so
Splunk server let me get rid of this and
then I have the raw data which we have
seen earlier but let's go ahead and
split this because if you just double
click on one value it tells me that it
talks about the time it talks about an
IP address it says date it has a device
name device ID login ID type so it
basically gives me subtype it has user
statistics and all this so let's play
around with this one and let's break
this or split this so what I can do here
is I can and go ahead and select this
and I can choose split and I can go by
delimiter now delimiter can be chosen
and I see that there is space as a
delimiter and I calculated if I look at
the event I can divide that into nine
different columns but rather than going
by delimiter I'll go by positions
and
it basically says these are the
positions you can anyways change the
number so it says something at 16th
position and then 30th position and so
on so you can do that you can just say
okay now what does that do it has
basically replaced my data with
different columns now that's based on
the positions so then we can basically
transform it in a better way so for
example I have these two which says
August and fifth but let's see if we
have any date field here which says I
have it talks about August 5th it talks
about the time so what I can do is I can
actually get rid of this one
so I can say let's choose this let's
choose this and let's go ahead and
remove these columns so that's gone so
you have time you have IP addresses
and let's basically look at this so I
have this time I have the date and then
I have time again so let's select this
and this and what I have noticed or I
have seen already that the time what you
have here and the time what you see here
as the event time is the same so let me
go ahead and remove these columns too so
that's also gone now we have the date as
the column so I can remove this one and
what I can do is this one I can rename
as date so let's choose this let's give
it a name let's call it date and that's
your date now this one is your time so
let's change this to time
and we can make it time so that's done
now here I have the IP address so for
example let's just call it let's just
rename this and let's call it IP
address so that's also done now let's
see what else we have so we have a host
IP here
and then we had an IP which shows up so
I do have this and basically these
values should be same so what I can do
is I can in fact get rid of this one
also remove this so date is fine time is
fine you have host now these are your
device name so let's basically give a
name to this column so I can say the
name I will call it device name
and that's fine what we will also do is
it will be easier to check so we can
replace this so I can say replace values
and let's give this pattern so I'll say
device name equals and I want to just
remove that so let's say okay and your
device name is gone similarly you have
device ID let's do the same thing so
first let's rename it to device ID so
that's my device ID and here I will
replace this so I will say replace
values and let's say device ID equals
has to be replaced or should be gone so
that's also done now you have your login
ID so let's get rid of this column
so
I will remove this and then here I have
I think it should be log ID or login ID
so let's rename this and let's call it
log ID
so that's also done now we can change
this data types so we have some Raw
event here which says type is event
subtype system so we can split this
again so let's take this let's do a
split and let's call it by say delimiter
so I can basically split it with
delimiter and that's going to create
four columns if we use equals
or I can go for position for example
let's go in here and let's try doing a
split
and this time let's go for position
and here
it gives me some positions so let's say
okay so it's giving me some error please
enter the value so let's say
4 5 9 10 let's say 10
and let's say 11
and then you have a space so let me just
choose this and check how it works so
you have your subsystem type
which is fine
but then I lose my event so I don't want
to lose anything so let me cancel this
let me cancel this okay and we have the
data here let's say type is event system
is subsystem
and I can basically have the information
here but then let's go ahead and ignore
this because this one would not be
really used in my search so I can in
fact remove this or I could have said
type and it will have even Subs type
will be system but that's going to
remain same so let me remove this column
now again I have raw format which talks
about level what kind of information it
is is it information is it notice you
have root ID you have log description
you have interface so let's go ahead and
split this one so let's do a split let's
go by positions and
we have the positions here so let's for
example
take
position of the characters here
so for example the first one could be
you have five and six eighteen so let's
say 18 and then let's go for other
values so that's again your let's go for
say 28
and then we have 28 and 7 35 36
36 and 541 42 and you have
four
what is six around 52 so let's go for 52
so what I did was the last column which
we had which we were splitting by
position so we can basically split based
on positions or the number of characters
but then sometimes in one bit of
information you might have indefinite
number of characters so choosing the
splitting based on characters or
positions might be inappropriate what we
can do is we can do a splitting and I
can go for delimiter and this time in
custom I will instead of custom I'll go
for space which should basically
consider every space as the delimiter it
automatically identifies the maximum
number of columns which will be created
is 13 we get anyways get it or delete
some of those which we don't need so
let's say okay
and it has done the splitting so now you
have all this as level so let me rename
this so you have to work with
transforming your data before that can
be loaded in the way you want so let's
this be level and let's also replace
this like we did earlier with level
equals and then replace it so that
becomes your information or notice now
this is your VD which is
Law related to your login so for example
let's keep this so I will rename this to
v d and then we can basically replace
all the values here so let's call it VD
equals
and then replace it with nothing so that
gives me the root user
I also have the description here which
tells me where is this information
coming from so let's rename this to log
description
and then once that is done we will also
replace the values so I'll say replace
and I will go for log description equals
replaced with nothing so that gives me
log description here we have interface
or action so this is what we have which
basically
has some values now if I go into the
filter it tells me it talks about the
count or it talks about the interface or
it talks about status so there are
various Fields now we could keep it as
it is and we know that there is this
delimiter so let's just call it type
and that's enough so now you have the
total which talks about the count or CPU
so we have
messages right how many times it was
used what kind of Statistics it is right
and we have a lot of information here
which we can use and we can filter this
but
it depends on what kind of information
I'm looking from this particular data
set I'm really going for something like
totaling or something like CPU count so
you always have these filters which
tells me okay if you are looking for
what kind of messages you have what kind
of information you have so let us have
that as it is this one talks about your
action or it talks about your message
and so on so I would not need this so
let me remove this one then I have
message which talks about statistics it
talks about total sessions so either I
can focus on the message or I can look
at how many sessions were there so
that's something which we can look at
and we can
do a filter so for example I can say
text filters and let's say begins with
and let's say
either you have message begins with we
can choose one of these so either I
could say total session
or I could keep message or I could keep
IPS so I can have specific kind of data
so let's say yeah so let's do one thing
first we will do some filtering here so
first I will say replace
the values and I can basically keep it
as message
total sessions and IP address these are
the three things I would be interested
in and rest of the things can be taken
off so what I will do is here I will say
unselect all then I will go for Action
is login action is log out
I can look for the IP
values I can look at message values
and then you have your total sessions so
if you are really looking for a count of
total sessions or we could have split
this data filtered it out and created
different columns out of it so let's go
for because message we already have so
let's go for total sessions so here I
will basically say I'm only interested
in
begins with
and let's say
total session and I will just say I am
interested in total session values let's
filter it so that gives me
total sessions
and if you see here it might affect the
kind of information what you are
collecting if you are using this
particular filter so let's keep it
Dynamic let's clear the filter now I do
have information about your disk your
bandwidth not interested your setup rate
so let's take this let's take this let's
take this let's take this log rate I
will remove these columns
then I have my other information message
performance statistics not interested
remove these columns so I have my list
of columns now we do see that the user
is root here in most cases so VD and
what we can do is we can remove this
because if it's all column values or
common values we don't need it log ID
it's not relevant and I have filtered
out my data with as date which has time
device name device ID IP address what is
the source type so this is we will keep
this which can be useful and now we have
our timestamp here which basically has
the data but we have date and time which
is given here so we can either keep one
of these or I can keep the time column
so that I can sort it out based on time
or based it on
dates so let's choose this and this
which is
628 this is in a different time zone so
let me get rid of this one so I'll say
remove now
that's basically the data which I have
looks good which we can use so I will
say close and apply
and
that's applying my changes now this is
one simple data set which we took from
firewall and which has particular Fields
so you see there is a date field now
date field is basically you can look at
the date hierarchy you have year quarter
month day and you can choose work on it
so you have some raw fields and we can
rename those so we will see that so we
have our data which is getting loaded
and that's your CPU which we had we have
the total sessions which we are seeing
here
okay and we have some systematic
information let's also go back here home
and what I can do is I can go into
transform just a quick run through the
data
so we have the eyepiece host
log description now these are my raw
fields which talk about the type which
talk about the total and which talk
about the messages so let's give them
some name rather than keeping so we can
call them this is type let's rename this
and let's call it type 1 info
let's call this one type 2 info
and then let's call this one type 3 info
today so I remove the column sorry
so type 2 info and then you have
type 3 info type
3 info and so you see we had some raw
data or data coming in from logs but we
have transformed it let me just do a
close and apply and that's my one data
set which we have which will have these
fields if you see the names right and it
shows me the kind of information we have
now depending on the filters so you have
these different filters I can select all
and it shows me all the information I
can unselect these and I can say okay
I'm interested in looking at the
information where IP is 250 hundred and
let's select that
and basically then it gives me the kind
of log description messages what is the
type of info and again in this I have
just interface information in this I'm
seeing DHCP message right so I can
remove the filter but then my filter
works perfectly fine so this is the data
I have and
we are good to go with this one so I can
basically save this if this is what I'm
interested in let's call it something so
let's say 40 gate
event report
save it
and that's basically the report which I
have saved with this information
although we have not done any kind of
visualization on this so this is good
now let's take a stream HTTP data and
work on it and we can see how we can
connect these so for example let's go in
here so let's select all files so we
took this data now we have a traffic
data it would be interesting if you
would want to look at the data before
because then you would know what data
can be collected so if we look at this
data which is in a CSV format looking in
Excel so it's trying to read that and
then we will see what are the fields
which we can use to map different
information so you might have some
firewall information about an IP you
might have the traffic information you
might have the DNS information you might
have the attack or the malware
information and all that information can
be joined together by recreating a mod
which can have a relationships and then
basically create visualization which
relates to the data coming in from
different data sets so you could do a
join you can have multiple data sets and
you can go for a left join right join
you can merge different data sets you
can do that but data modeling does make
your work easier where you can have your
facts and dimension tables you can
basically have more meaning to it so it
says find not loaded completely that's
okay we will filter this now if you see
here this also has a host information it
has time
and it basically talks about server and
then you have your raw data which
basically is your timestamp device ID
what we were seeing and then you have
your login ID like we had in previous
example right and then this is basically
the traffic information so if I
basically take one such field here I
could see what is the kind of
information it contains
it gives me the traffic information what
is the source protocol right so this is
my one event which I'm looking at it
tells me uh what was the
transaction IB what was the transport
Port what was the service which was used
is what it was a Microsoft portal which
was being used uh what was the
application risk what was detected how
many bytes were sent how many bytes were
received right so this is basically
giving me some traffic information now
we might be able to use this if I really
want to see from one particular Source
IP
if you look at the source IP here and to
the destination IP how many bytes or how
many packets were sent and that might be
something which we want to query or
visualize and find out if there is
basically huge amount of data flowing
out or flowing in so we can take this
data so looks interesting so let's not
save it and I will go ahead here and
what I will do is this is my one data
set so let's go in home let's go to get
data Excel
let's go in here
I am looking at all files look at the
traffic data open obviously that's huge
data so we want to transform this we can
even limit the number of rows or select
particular IPS which we would want to
look at so as we did last time let's
remove the serial number not needed time
we will have in other fields so let's
get rid of that source is fine Source
type is fine host is fine index not
needed
your server not needed you have the raw
data which has to be basically split and
this is the data which we have now we
can select certain important Fields here
so let's go ahead and do a split and
let's go for positions
and if you see it identifies the
position it basically knows that there
are these positions of values are at
these positions which we can then merge
or say for example I could have gone
simply by space so if I say let's go in
by split columns
by delimiter let's choose space as the
delimiter let's say okay
and that basically gives me columns so
let's go in for this one August this one
so
we will see if we have any time field so
we don't have any time field as of now
this is what we have we have date we
have time which can be merged together
if we are interested in so what I can do
is I can remove these columns
right so it becomes so easy with power
bi where you're working with bigger data
sets although the data is in structured
format but even if it is not you can use
all these things to basically split the
data now here we have some timing so
let's get rid of this one
let's remove this one so there is
repeated information you have host and
this one let's remove this
because all the information in a raw
format is stored in one particular
column so you have date and time so we
can keep the date and time together
we can concatenate it
uh we can basically merge it and make it
one so let's say first let me replace
this so I will basically go ahead and
rename or let's say replace and I'm
going to replace all the date equals
with nothing so that purely gives me the
date and this one is time so let's
replace everything with time so time
equals and then replace it with nothing
and then I choose this and this and I do
a merge
and let's call it separator Let It Be I
can give a colon or I can give a comma
or I can give a space space looks good
let's call it date and time or let's say
it's just a date
so that's my data looks good so you have
device name you have your device ID like
what we had so we don't need this one
which we deleted so let's get rid of
that so type you can always see how many
values you have so if it is type is
traffic let it be so let's quickly
replace this one with device name
and then basically go ahead and oh I did
it remove but not to worry I can just
cancel this and I have it back so now I
can replace the values here and let's
say device name is replaced with just
the name
similarly this is device ID so let's do
that device ID and we will still do a
replacing here so I will say replace all
the values and device ID equals is
replaced with the actual value now type
is traffic let that be it's a type of
information which might be useful for us
so let's go ahead and rename this and
let's call it type 1 info
and here I will replace all the values
of type equals
there should be multiple other simpler
ways of doing it you can transform the
data using a programming language you
can do that so this tells me there are
some subtypes which are about because we
are talking about the traffic data so it
says subtype which is forward or local
now that depends on what kind of
information you're searching for but
let's keep this so I will rename this I
will call it subtype might be we can
take this and keep it in a different
column or different table all together
so we can do that so subtype and let's
say replace
the values here
subtype equals is replaced with just the
value
then you have the level you can see what
kind of levels you have it just says
notice that's the only one value so
let's get rid of this one
now you have the source IP you have the
source Port which can be very useful
information so let's rename this and
let's call it Source IP
go ahead and replace the values here so
let's say replace and I'm going to say
Source IP equals is replaced with
everything so that's gone and now you
have your Source ports which could also
be important so let's go ahead and
rename this let's call it Source port
and
let's replace the values
Source Port equals and that's basically
gone now we can go further we can look
at the source and what is this kind of
information so here it tells it's a
source
uh
internal source Port what we are seeing
and we have some internal or some other
information so there might be various
other messages but all of these refers
to the same key and value so let's
rename this we'll see how we can use all
of this information so I'll call it
int F and then I'm going to replace this
Source intf equals is replaced because
we have given the column name now you
have the destination ipn destination
Port very important information so let's
go ahead and rename this let's call it
destination IP which might be just
meaning IP in some other
uh some other data set so let's do a
destination IP let's replace the values
now with dstip equals is gone
and
the same thing here
DSD port
that's the name
and then replace
I could have done that easily in Excel
also but then it's good to view the data
and then make the changes here so
destination port
and then you have your this one so it
basically has some values might be we
don't need this so let me remove this
column
and and I will remove this column also I
don't need it
so I till I have my source IPS and Port
destination IP and Port which we can
even merge with a particular column but
let's keep it separate in case we would
want to pull out the information then
you have your raw information which says
session IDs and all that so let's get
rid of this let's get rid of this let's
get rid of this
and anytime you can basically see what
kind of information it has so it has
some session IDs we are looking at the
bytes going in and out
so let's remove these columns that's
gone you have
policy ID okay and action so let's
keep these so this one basically has
either your policy ID or destination
country information and what has
happened is based on the position
sometimes you see the destination ID or
country either in this field or in this
field right so you have destination
country Source country destination
country and Source country so this
information
what we are seeing here
is something which has split based on
the positions what we have so we have uh
position ID which has action so let's
look at these so we have yeah so we have
action we have policy ID destination
country
Source country and then you have these
fields so what we will have to do is if
we have to extract the values and create
this as a new column so for example I
had this and I could basically say
duplicate columns
and then I can basically say one can
just have my policy ID values one can
have my destination ID values so it
depends on the kind of information we
are looking at we don't want to lose any
particular data here but let's see so we
have action let me do one thing let's
say action let's say raw 23 24
destination
Source country so you have a service
which tells you about what kind of
service was used
what was the duration
you have to just make sure that you
don't have any fields which are being
missed because of the data what we have
so well we have the actions policy ID
destination country Source country
what kind of Transport was used what
kind of service was used
and this is where it gets challenging
because you have lots and lots of fields
so if you see here all these fields are
nulls so first let's take this let's
take this
so you have
Fields where there might be data down
the line I mean it does not mean that
all these fields so you see here there
is some data in the underlying rows
but it depends on what is the
information we are looking for so for
now I will just choose this we can do a
lot of work here but let's not get into
everything let's do a remove
let's just see step by step the critical
ones and let's
go all the way here let's do a remove we
don't need this data so here we have
your application category your
collaboration your app risk now this
could be useful
so let's do one thing let's keep this
this because remember we have a text
filter which can be used to filter out
the data so I can basically choose these
fields
as one
transport
uh let's keep
this one and we will test it so we have
these fields let's take this
last one yeah and let's do a merge
column
okay and I will basically say let the
delimiter be either comma which could be
useful
so let's go for comma and let's call
this
info
so that's my data which has been split
now say for example if I would want to
filter out some values I do have
something like this and I could
basically go for text filter I can say
contains and let's go for something like
United
and now you will see wherever your
values are United States that shows up
but you can be more specific in saying I
want the destination country so I can
basically say
clear the filter let's go in here let's
go for text filters let's say
contains
and let's say
destination country
equals and let's say United let's just
search for this particular pattern
and now you will see you have only the
destination country being United States
right so that basically allows you to
filter out the data for now I can clear
the filter so looks good we have some
useful data and this is your traffic
related data what we have so let's
basically close and apply
and depending on the size of the data
set you can have it taking some time so
we could filter out we could have said
okay I'm not interested in anything
which goes after or before August 19th
because this is I think data coming in
from 2016 2017 and we can choose the
year so but let it get loaded we can
anyways do a transformation and we can
check for information
but this is how you are basically
creating data sets which has different
fields now we can then change the data
type as I explained we can transform
this data we can basically relate these
data sets and extract information out of
it we can create visualizations out of
it and
let's see what is the size of this data
so it tells me we have
well that's a huge data set let's say
if you see that's almost four gigabytes
so
88 yeah so it's a 4 gigabyte data set
might be we have to
uh cancel this
and
there are some pending changes but let's
let's reduce it so what I'll do is I'll
go for transformation
and I'll do a transform
and we have these different filters but
let's go for the date
field which talks about
something and it tells me 2016.
right so we can select this and what I
can do is I can do a transform
by ear
and let's say I'm saying here doesn't
look good
so that's only giving me how many values
do I have I have only 2016. so let's do
a load more to see if there are many
other values
nothing specific so let's go ahead and
remove this
okay so I would be interested in it's
all August 8th but then might be I can
pick up a date which is going to reduce
the data so we have eight one two how
many entries we have we have
say for example 24th and I know that
there is some problem in 23 onwards so
let's choose from 820 onwards
so I'm going to
unselect all and then I'm going to say
let's go for a 20 21 22 23 24 28 and
anything before that
now let's take 29 and let's do a load
more to check if we are missing on any
dates no
so let's go for
select all
right now you could go here and you can
say date filters and you can basically
say the month or the day
right so is not latest you can choose is
earliest in the next in the previous
before after so if I go for after
now it tells me
you need to choose a particular date so
I could straight away say let's choose
anything which goes after 8 19
right and now you have 28
so that's basically selecting some data
so we can then also say
if we want data for particular subset so
for example let's choose this now let's
say close and apply it should
substantially
reduce the data now if you see here
since I am doing a close and apply it's
trying to load both the data sets which
we have
and that might again take time so you
have to choose once you have transformed
if the data set which remains in your
query editor if that should be loaded
when you are loading the other data sets
sometimes if you're working on multiple
data sets that might be a bigger problem
so let's give it some time and we will
check once the data is loaded
so both the data sets have been loaded
now and if you look into the 40 gate
event data so that basically has my
dates and we can check that it has
everything Beyond 20 as we chose
and let's look at the traffic data so if
I look at the traffic data now this one
basically has dates which are
even before 20 so it is trying to load
the columns and it has all the dates and
what we will do is we'll try to sync the
data and we will keep it
Beyond 8 20 like what we had in the
previous data set so let's have this one
selected and let's go in here and I will
say transform and I will go for
transforming the data again which I
forgot to do earlier or we can just
reduce the data because the data sets
might be huge and once you have prepared
your model and if you have a bigger
system then you can go for loading all
the data so we have the time and date
field here
and then we have
other fields which we are looking at but
this one basically has time which shows
up everything we can again merge this as
date and time like what we have in our
traffic data so let's quickly check in
traffic data we have date and time
so let's go in here
and we have the date and time so let me
just bring it here and then we can
basically first merge them so I have the
date and time but we are interested only
in data which is after or from 20
onwards
so first let me basically
apply a filter here
so we can go for date filter I can say
after that's the easier way let's go in
and select from 20 or let's say
let's go in here and this shows me 19
let's choose 19 and let's go for okay
that should basically Now give me only
data which is 20 and
Beyond and now let's select date and
time and let's merge this with a space
in between so let's call separator as
space
and let's call it date
let's say okay
and that's merged so we have the time
here which is 11 58
and
in rest of the fields so that looks good
to me and now let's do a close and apply
but remember my I'm working on event
data and traffic data was already loaded
and it is a bigger data set so I can
select this I can say enable load again
so do I continue
and now let's select this where we
really made the changes let's do a close
and apply
and that's done because this was not a
bigger data set and now we can quickly
check so in the date fields we are
looking at the event data so you have
everything starting Beyond 820 so
anything before 820 is gone
and that's fine with us and
what we need is the the traffic data
also so let's go back because that was
not loaded but we really need that so
let's go in home
let's go to the transform
let's choose this it was not loaded
and let's enable load so let's check yes
this is fine
and let's go ahead and
basically close and apply
so now it's only going to get me the
traffic data so earlier we had the event
data that was already loaded so you can
select data sets step by step and then
load them so in that case it can be
faster you can reduce the time how much
it takes now obviously once you have
filtered out all the data which you are
interested in and that is already loaded
then we can basically create a data
model which can join these
data sets based on device name based on
device ID based on IPS and we can create
a link between these so now that the
data has been loaded for these two kind
of sources we can basically look into
the fields what these have so you have
device ID device name destination IP
destination port and similarly you have
the events here which has device ID
device name so we can basically get rid
of some columns or some columns we can
keep them with the same naming
conventions so this one basically has a
date dot one field
which we can change
and here we have date so
let's look at this one and I'm looking
at the date field here which basically
says State DOT one which doesn't look
good so let's rename this let's call it
date
and remember this is a bigger file based
on the time or the date or any other
filtering criteria which we have chosen
so either you reduce the amount of date
so that you can break it down and your
processing can be faster or when you
would be using say Microsoft bi that
would be working on a powerful machine
which could store it now once this is
done what we also would want to do is we
would want to work on loading one more
data set so this is firewall data and I
would be also interested in HTTP data
which also gives me information of the
HTTP different methods such as you have
have post you have request and so on so
we can do that now this state column
looks good you have type 1 type 2 type
informations you have device name which
says Dev name Dev ID so that looks good
to me and let's go in here let's look
into this one so we have Dev name Dev ID
so those names are fine you have your
destination IP destination Port you have
the host name you have the info you have
source and Source type
so let's look at the traffic data
and this is where we have your Source
IPS your Source Port destination IP
which looks like a DNS server and you
have your host IP so you can see what
other information you have so if I just
scroll this I have source and Source
type which is showing up right here in
the beginning
and if you compare this one so this also
has a source and Source type
which basically uniquely identifies
where the data is coming in from and
obviously we can arrange the columns in
the way they look the order of those we
can merge and manage them so this this
looks good now let's go in here let's go
to get data let's go to excel let's
choose
one more file
and I would be interested in HTTP I can
look into this when event log which
looks like a one gigabyte file this one
looks like a smaller 28 megabytes file
so let's take this one and that's
getting loaded here we would want to
transform this data
okay so let's get rid of Serial let's
filter that out now we can see there is
this
Time Field which is here but we can
split that out so let the time be let's
not take this one let's remove this so
stream Source host
index we don't need let's get rid of
this let's get rid of Splunk server now
let's look at Host information
and that basically gives me a similar
kind of server name so let's not even
use this one now comes our raw field if
you double click on one of these it
shows me a lot of information here and
it is in the form of you have your data
is separated by comma here so we can
basically choose comma as the delimiter
splitting the data and then you can have
Consolidated information so let's go
ahead this one let's do a split column
let's go by delimiter and I'm going to
choose
comma
and let's say
okay
and that basically shows me the column
so you have your
end time timestamp now these two can be
merged
and we can replace the brackets so
that's fine you have acknowledgment
packets information
you'll have bytes by 10 bytes out you
have Source IP which is CIP you have
cached so we can get rid of these we can
so you see there are these number of
columns now let's work on this so first
let's get this and this
so first let's replace this so we have
everything starting with the end time so
let's call it head and rename this to
end time
that's done now we'll just do a replace
values and what do you want to replace
so let's use this bracket let's say end
time and colon now that one should be
gone
so that looks better
we have the timestamp also and if you
carefully look at the timestamp here so
you have the timestamp which can be
brought out from this one let's do a
second level replace
and what I'll do is I'll choose anything
starts with t
I can do a wild card
ending with c
and let's try this and it does not find
this particular pattern okay let's do it
in a different way so I can do a replace
and we can basically say
T should be replaced with a space
so now you have t which is gone
and we basically have the date and time
so what we can do is it will take little
bit of work here where you have to merge
the date and time so the easier way
would be basically splitting this data
based on a delimiter so we have these
time stamps embedded with the time so
what I can do is I can go ahead here and
do a split column by delimiter now I
know that there is a Time D limiter T so
let me split by that and now I have my
time which also shows that in a date
time format you have n time which is
also having a timestamp so first is
let's clear this off let's get rid of
this column and now the end time I can
basically here again do a splitting of
this by delimiter and this time my
delimiter will be 8
custom and then let's choose a DOT here
and let's split it based on the dot so
that gives me the timestamp which is
automatically formatted which looks good
although we have to take care if it is
in our or 12 hours or 24 hours format so
now we don't need this we can get rid of
this and that's the simplest way and
then basically I can do a merge of
this and this let's do a merging with a
space as the delimiter so let's call it
space
and let's call it date and let's do a
merging
in simple way we have the data here now
the time and everything can be formatted
but that gives me some information it
tells me packets in packets out by its
bytes bytes in bytes out
and we can basically Club this
information so I can basically say your
acknowledgment packets so if you see
here you have acknowledgment packets in
so these are the only values which you
have and we can get rid of
all these values which says accept and
accept so we don't we are not interested
in this we are interested in
acknowledgment packets in and out
and that looks good so bytes we can look
at the filters and it basically gives me
all the bytes value let's keep that so
you have bytes in bytes out now these we
could have basically
filtered out and given column names so
like we did earlier so we can just do a
rename and let's say acknowledgment
packets
in that's going to be my column name and
then let's just replace the values here
which is basically going to search for a
c k underscore packet
underscore in Colon should be replaced
or should be basically gone so
let's get rid of that
so it's still working on it it might be
huge data
and similarly we can work on this one to
do a replace and let's call it
acknowledge pack underscore out
let's choose this column let's do a
replace values and we want acknowledge
packet
out
colon should be replaced with space so
just the values there and we have given
the fields right then that should be
fine so let's get rid of this overall
bytes we would be more interested in
looking at bytes in and bytes out
so let's go in here and let's rename
this to
bytes underscore in
and then
basically
replace the values or you could keep
that with a key value pair if that's
what you would want to keep so bytes in
with a colon should be replaced
so that works fine so this one is still
taking time let's see
we did a replace
and we said acknowledgment
packets out
that was the pattern
replace it with nothing
yeah so now it's working
and then you basically do a replace you
have to be careful with the
case sensitiveness and let's replace
this
oh it doesn't look good
so let me again do a replace
and I want the semicolon to be gone
yeah and bytes in similarly you have
bytes out
so let's say bytes underscore out
and
replace this by its underscore out
and then you basically have your client
IP
which shows up here now do you want to
go for caching no
do you want to go for capture hostname
not exactly client rtt client packets
client sum let's get rid of these
so that's gone so connection type which
basically has you can always look at the
values which says
connection type close or keep alive not
interested this version not interested
so basically we can
if there is lot of information which you
might be using later so you have some
data packets in data packets out
and let's see we already had here byte
send bytes out
so let's go in here and let me
do this thing so before I work on the
client IP let me take this take this
take this
all this information here
and let's basically merge these
and we can keep
comma as separator and let's call it
info
so that's merged
and then you have data packets in and
data packets out so let's quickly rename
this so before doing that just check the
values here so you have data center time
now we have the time Factor already and
it talks about data packets in and out
and that's basically in values or out
values so we don't need the data center
values so let's go ahead and basically
get rid of this
so now the data has been transformed I
have basically replaced the client IPS
and all the other data which would be
better if we keep as one so this remains
because this has embedded information
and we don't want to lose any data so it
would be good to keep it here and then
we can do a Content search on this so
this is the data which has been modified
now I already had these data sets so I
can basically choose enable load
I will remove this
I will basically go for this one which
is enable load
and then I am only interested in this
one so let's do a save close and apply
so the changes have been made now these
changes will be applied now if you see
my older data sets are already here and
I really did not want to go through the
whole process of reloading them so I
have just worked on this stream HTTP
data
and I am just loading this one so this
shouldn't take much time and we should
have the data loaded now once we have
this now similarly you can work on all
the data sets so I do have the source
source type you have the dates and if
you closely see here all the dates is
basically Beyond and it's only 828 so I
do have information but here I am
looking at
the date field and that basically shows
me all the fields here so
looks like we have to filter out the
date because that can again be whose
data it tells me there is 21
758 rows there are columns with these
many distinct values so it gives me this
but
let's do a last level of filtering so I
am going to work on transforming this
so
let's go in and transform this one again
and here you have the date
and we were interested only in 8 20
onwards so let's make sure that
this is the date we have
okay the best option would be first
basically splitting this so let's go
ahead for split this
by a particular delimiter and here my
delimiter will be
space
and then we can
re-merge the data so this is being split
date 1 and date two now I can go here
and
it does show me only these dates but
let's make sure so I'll say after
and we will look into
oh I'm sorry so what we are doing here
is we are
removing this let's not split this this
was actually fine because I was looking
into the event data which is fine we
have to focus on
this one so this is where my date
has
it looks to me in a date string format
which is not good so let's do a split
by a delimiter
and let's say the delimiter b space
and let's say okay
so I know it will basically have these
two so it basically has split the data
and now what we will do is we will go in
here it shows me
yeah so it looks shows me all the dates
which we are not interested in we are
interested in only
these states
well I could have said after and that
would be an easier approach
yeah so this is fine now we have the
dates now
we have applied this filter so let's
take this column
and this column again
let's merge the columns
let's have space as the delimiter let's
call it date
and let's say so we have all these
values now this column which was also
extracted from here could not be merged
so let me remove this so we have to
spend some time in doing this data
angling stuff and now let's do a close
and apply only for this HTTP data
and now we only see the stream data set
which is available here first let's
confirm
so we have successfully transformed our
three bigger data sets one is HTTP
related and two are traffic and events
now this is how the as of now there is
no relationship between them if we would
want to
visualize the data which comes in from
One Source or joins with other source we
will have to create relationship between
them however we can look at the fields
and we can try to understand so let's
look into the data set quickly now if we
look into the event data so we have our
source source type
we basically have the host we also have
the date and time which is there in each
of the data sets so you have uh
basically the date here
which we can see in traffic data so we
have the date we have event that also
has the date however the format is
little different and what we can do is
we can basically look at the data we can
we can see that it is in a text format
and if we would want to change we can do
that however date is not the concern the
other fields have been transformed so we
look at total number of sessions we look
at the type of information what kind of
information we have what is the kind of
device ID
so this is what we are seeing in
event now in traffic I have
my hostname I have the date I have
device name device ID
and these device names and device IDs if
we look at the other one
that is event so these would be same
and then you have other information
which is related to Traffic here so you
look at the source IP you look at the
type of information and then if you look
in stream HTTP you have packets in
packets out bytes and bytes out so let's
basically now create a visualization
taking the information from all these
three now we can either explicitly
Define relationship or when we are
creating the visualization we can go
ahead with the relationship so let's go
here and let me first choose your stream
HTTP so I have the client IP I have the
source and Source type
so what I will do is I will basically
say for example let's start with your
event and traffic data so let's have
a merger between these so let's select
event
and here let's select
the date column
so let me bring the date here now that
basically gives me the date and the time
and
that basically looks fine now you also
have your device ID so let's bring the
device ID
which shows me the device ID let's bring
the device name
so this is the information I want now I
can get the source so that I know where
all the data is coming from so let's
take the source and drop it here
so that basically tells me the source
I also have the source type so let's
choose the source type which tells me
event and then we basically have say
for example type info that is the field
I have so for example let me select type
1 bring it here
and that tells me what is the kind of
information I have either it is account
or basically it's an action which we can
basically then create some filters to
filter out the data
let's look at type 2 info and that
basically gives me type 2 info which is
either talking about CPU or total count
so let me just get rid of type 2 info
that doesn't look so interesting let's
look at type 3 info
and that basically gives me some total
session and DH DHCP statistics so we
will just keep type 1 info here and now
I will choose the traffic traffic
and here I will choose the destination
IP so let's bring it here now when I do
this it says cannot display the visual
fix this let's go ahead and fix this it
says do you want to do a auto detection
of the result let's do that
so it basically says there were no
relationships which were detected let's
go to manage relationships
and since there is huge data it has to
basically
you have to give the control to power bi
fill up the fields so it is basically
showing me the from table name and two
table name and if we have some
relationships which can be created
so
I can click on new
and here let's choose event which
basically has the host device name
device type and so on
and here let's choose traffic
now
I have basically the device name
and that basically can be chosen and
device name can be chosen here and I can
say
this shows as many to many relationship
and if you see this relationship as
cardinality many to many there should
only be used if it is expected that
neither column that is device name and
device name contains unique values so if
it has unique values then you can go for
one too many
so we can basically go ahead here and
say one to one for example but it says
it is invalid let's go to one too many
and again it says so the only which is
expected is many to many
and choose this
so it basically says there is a
relationship established between device
name and device name I can also say new
again choose and here choose traffic
so we have device name also so let's
select this our device name is already
done so device ID and then device ID
here
and let's make this active
or I could have just said okay
so let's say okay
and now you have device ID and device
name let's also see something else so
let's look at new and I will choose
event so I have all this information
which is
giving me the type of information what
we have total number of sessions what is
the performance statistics and all that
but then these might not have the same
columns here
so what are the same columns we have so
we have traffic we have Source IP we
have Source port
and then we have information which we
would want to pull out but let's
basically
go in here and we can define a
relationship between Source IP and here
we have the host IP so if we know that
this is the host where we are looking at
so for example if I choose host and if I
choose Source IP now I can say
okay
so these are some of the relationships I
am creating
and then I can
you can't create a direct active
relationship between event traffic
because an active set of indirect
relationships already exist between
these tables to make this relationship
active set the cross filter direction to
single delete or deactivate any of the
indirect relationships first
so we have direct and indirect
relationships which we can choose now we
have
if for example I remove this and then if
I select this so I'm saying let the host
and the source IP be my relationship
let's click on close
and now let's see
let the data get populated
So based on the columns which we have
chosen and now we are interested in the
information here
so let's look at the model meanwhile so
you see the kind of relationships you
have created
so there is basically your destination
so you have the star symbolizes many to
many so we basically have many to many
relationship and that basically depends
on the column names which we have mapped
now if I go back here
and this is where I can be seeing so
let's go into traffic and let's drag and
drop the type one info here
and we will have to give it some time
because now it is trying to detect based
on the device ID device names it is
trying to match
the value of your source
which we have chosen here with the host
information
and those values have to be same because
that's the relationship we have made
active
and then we will see the result because
it has to basically filter out the
hostname
here
and you have the
Source IP
which we chose here so let me go back to
the relationships and that's your device
name device name this is your device ID
device ID this is your Source IP and
host
let's go back to visualization
so since we have established a
relationship I can select this I can
delete this and I can go for
visualization again so let's now
go ahead and start selecting
say for example date field
now I will choose the device ID
let's go for device name
device name
let's make this bigger
and then let's go for source
I would want to keep the source so it
tells me
what is the source type
right we can get rid of source for now
Source type is fine and let's also go
for
foreign
host
so that basically gives me my host
values and we can just to check since we
have linked our host with the source IP
in the relationship let's also choose
destination IP
Source IP
and finally your
type info
now this is basically huge data what we
are looking at
so
it is basically saying filters on these
visuals which we can basically control
so here if you see you can do a sorting
you can add some list so right now we
have added these filters and we will
have to give it some time where it can
populate so meanwhile you can either do
a show as stable you can go in here
and then scroll down
and you have data fields here filters on
the page which we can apply now let's go
to the drill through
so let's go to the formatting and let's
go to the grid
and you want to have vertical grid so
let's switch it to on let's make it
black
and now I have basically
your horizontal grid color so let's
create that also as black
now we can go for font size so let's
increase that
that's your text size
depending on your screen
and image height that's fine now column
headers
you can look at the font color what's
the background color
text size let's make it bigger
and then you have your values
so this is fine and now you have your
totals if you have
field formatting so we can choose the
date field which we have chosen
and we can choose this which basically
says do you want to Auto align it or you
want to change something you want to
give a title so these are all the
options which you can use for formatting
and let's go in here
and let's go to the filter here
so remember it is going for
my when you look at the filter it is
telling me these are the host IPS which
it will be looking for
this is the source types it will be
looking for
this is the source IPS which it is
and we can either select
one of the source IP
depending on the count what we have here
to filter out the data
or it's going to be trying to match all
the entries here now we are looking at a
bigger data set
so let me choose
here
a particular value for example there are
three entries for this particular IP
being the source IP and we have type 1
info we can see what kind of information
it contains it talks about traffic
now that's what we wanted based on our
host and Source IPS
so this looks good we just need to make
sure that the host field
was Connected To Source IP so let's go
in here and select let's search for
something
so there is a 250 entry here
okay we can come back to the visual
let's go back to the table here and
let's look at some data
so we are looking at event let's
look at the host value which is 192
168.250.1
that's my host and here let's look at
in traffic
let's look at the source IPS sorry the
source and then you basically have the
host
which has the same values so host and
Source IB so what we created as a
relationship might be we have to
basically check that
so now that uh using the relationship
what I also did was earlier we were
creating multiple relationships and that
can also slow down the process so what
you can always do is you can go back
here and if you see I have created a
relationship between host to host
because I know the values can be synced
in sync or same across these so if you
would want to work on a relationship you
can just go ahead and delete this and
that's basically
gone
so your relationship is gone and now
your visual report if you go back will
show that there is some error because
there is no relationship established now
let's look at the fields again so we
have this particular information which
is saying that we have our data set so
let's look into the stream HTTP data set
now this is where we have basically
packets in packets out so we have the
source and Source type which basically
are giving us the same information so we
can choose one of these in HTTP and then
you also have your date you have packets
in packets out bytes in so you have
total bytes now this is what we can
focus on or we can be looking at what is
the total number of bytes bytes in bytes
out so this is the information coming
from HTTP now again you have the client
IP here so your client IP has 192 168
250 100 so basically let's try to match
that here now when you look at the HTTP
traffic
and if you look at destination IP now
that's the basically server so you can
always see what are the kind of values
you have so you have different values
here
and this is where the connections have
gone you have your Source IP which is
basically showing up
different values again so you have
different Source IPS you have different
destination IPS and you have the host
name which is 251.
that's your only host name in this one
in the traffic
now if we look at type 1 info then we
are looking at these columns now since
the data is huge you don't see these
other columns but then we can obviously
refresh and we can see if these columns
are showing up so you have more number
of columns which are here which will be
used so you have Source IB you have
destination IB and so on
and if we look at the information from
your event you basically have your
source
you have your host
so let's take host the wise the wise ID
from here
now we have the level let's see how many
values you have so you have alert
information notice warning so we can
then filter out only warning messages if
we are interested in
so I could be just saying warning so we
can choose level from here we have your
log description which talks about kind
of Statistics what is the info so is it
performance statistics
and then you have your CPU total session
so now for example let's go to visual
and if I would have to create a
relationship I will have to choose
different fields now the only one thing
which we need to understand is in stream
HTTP you have your client IP now let's
look at those values here
stream http
which basically has your client IP
let's look at the source
and also we can work on the date
field here so this is in AM or PM
what values we are seeing
and let's have the date field in
event
that's also showing AM or PM
so let's first create a relationship
between Sgt and stream sdtp
and what we can do is
let's keep it here
let's bring it here
so what I can do is I can have from
stream http
a relationship with the date here
so there can be date now there are these
formats which we can change if that is
giving a problem
let's say okay
however it is advisable let me just
delete this
let's go back here
okay
so we want information from all these
three data sets and we do not want to
really go with the join condition we
basically want to join them either on
the date field or
basically your other fields which have
common values
so since there were many relationships
created and then we had to look into the
fields which had date time format in a
different way what I did was I did some
cleanup I removed the relationships as
of now and we I reloaded the data so
just let's look and understand that so
this one starting from our three
different data sets first let's look
into the event by clicking on this
now it shows me Source type it shows me
the host that is from where the request
is originating it shows me the date look
at that format here and then you have
device name device ID what is the type
of message and then you have some log
information based on which we can filter
out or pull out some specific
information now what we notice here is
hostname is 250.1 and we have only one
host field
so that's perfectly fine now let's look
into the other data set that's
traffic which will give me some traffic
information now here again if you look
at the second column the host is 251
which basically means I can create a
relationship between event and
traffic based on host field now
notice the date format has also been
changed we have device name device IDs
so that also should be the same values
and you have the type info so you can
look into what kind of information you
have and this is traffic information it
looks at the subtype and that tells me
either it is forward or local on which
we can create filters now you have the
traffic going to the source IP and you
have the source Port so Source IP
basically has different fields and we
will see
what is the source IB so you have a host
and then you have Source IP from which
the connection would be going to say
destination IP so you have destination
IB which have multiple fields and then
obviously you have info wherein you can
say for example select one of the fields
or just place your cursor here and tells
you what kind of information it has it
has an action it has policy ID it has
destination country Source country and
everything is separated by comma so if
you would want you can split this
complete information into comma into
different fields so that's your second
data set and the third data set is your
stream HTTP which basically has your
Source type it has the date again format
converted packets and packets out and
here you have client IP which is
basically showing let's look at the
values and it has various values now the
source IP in the previous data set and
the client IP here from where the
request is originating would be the same
one and then obviously you have the
information so now we can create a
visualization using these so we have the
model here now what I can do is I can
start creating relationships between
this one so here I have host and I can
have host connected to host here
so basically this has now what does it
say this should only be used if it is
expected that both the columns do not
have unique values but we know that
there is unique value which is
192 168 250.1 so if I say one to one
it basically says the cardinality you
selected is invalid for this
relationship if I basically go for apply
security filter in both the directions
it does not still work and you can look
at the cross filter which says single so
you can have a relationship between this
and this
so you can say but the thing here is
there are various combinations for these
particular values and that's why it is
saying this cardinality does not work so
let's go for many to many that's fine
and let's go for okay so you should have
a relationship now between host and your
host now what we can also do is we can
go for device name or device ID so I can
again create one more between device
name and device ID in case there are
different values
I can say okay so this is one more
relationship I'm creating between these
although I am not making this active so
we can see when we look at the star it
tells me that it is many to many now
what we can also do is as I explained so
you have your traffic which
basically has your Source IP and here
you have client IP so let's create a
relationship between client IP and
Source IP
and let's go for ok
so that's again the relationship between
these now these relationships should be
enough for me to pull out the
information from all these three data
sets which can be related on the same
date or which can could be based on the
values so we do have date what I have
done is I have filtered out the data as
I explained earlier which was 20 onwards
8 20 onwards but then I have changed
that to make the data set a little
smaller and I have chosen anything
beyond
8 23 and then up to 828
so now this is done let's go to
visualization and let's pull out the
information so let's say it is talking
about
a previous field which we have let's
close this
so I can say fix this
and here I can close this one so we
don't have any data fields right now so
now let's start selecting so let's first
go to event I will be interested in
the date field
and let's get the date now it is broken
down into your year quarter month and
day now we can change that format so
here we have your date field
which is basically being
broken down now I can just say date and
I don't want the date hierarchy so date
is fine which gives me the time you see
the starting time is 23 onwards now what
we are interested in is basically the
device name so we have created a
relationship and it is good to choose
the fields on which you have created the
relationship now we have the host field
so let's select that now there is one
entry for that and that shows me the
host field you have level which had two
values so let's select
whole level now you can always check
here
when you are looking at these particular
Fields you can sorry check here which
will tell me what are the different
values and if you want only a selected
value say for example we want warning
information or
basically alert information which is a
lesson number I can select that or I can
add that as a filter so I can do that so
let's for example
choose this level so that's done now
let's go to the traffic field so we have
date we have device ID we have device
name which we have already taken so
there is no point in taking device name
again we can look at the destination IP
so that's available from this data set
let's take the destination IB
now host is something which we have
already created a relationship we have
info we have Source type we have Source
IP
so let me go for Source IP from here
and I'm adding Source IP now I have the
info field which basically has the
overall text which has useful
information which we can pull out so we
have chosen the destination IP we have
chosen the source IP which we can do a
count on and then basically we have say
type 1 info
which basically has some specific field
so let's try adding this and we can see
what kind of data it contains and that
might be a larger field so it might take
sometimes time but then that's okay
and
that's your traffic that's your event
and now we have our HTTP data so this
one basically has your client IP which
would be same as host IP as I mentioned
earlier so let's select client IP
it got selected twice that's fine and
then you have your info as the column
you have bytes in bytes out you have
acknowledged packets in packets out and
you basically have your Source type so
we can select Source type just to keep
in track of the data is coming in from
which source but as of now I can just
choose bytes
in which might be interesting field to
look at if there are bytes coming in and
then you look at bytes out
so let's for now cancel this type 1 info
and this is the data which we are
creating the visualization now as I said
when you are selecting these particular
Fields it is going to look for the host
IP
it is going to look at my destination IP
now we can always go back to the data
set and check if what appears in host IP
does that appear in say Source IP or
client IB in a particular data set so
for example if I go in here and if you
see I have client IP which is basically
192 168 250 100 that's what I have
filtered for
in this particular stream HTTP data set
so if you go back to client IP that's
the value which is showing up and if you
look in traffic
so here we have our host or we basically
have our destination IP or Source IP so
let's look at the source IP and here I
can search for
the IP which we see as client IP so
let's see 192 168
250 and then let's search for 100 and
that shows me that there are entries for
this so it basically
is correct where we have created a
relationship between Source IP and
client IP we have pulled out this
information now let's go back to the
visualization it is still working on it
based on the data what we have now what
we can do is the level which we were
seeing here
so level which basically had
four values and we see there is a least
count of alert so let's choose this
and that should basically faster or make
my query faster because now I am
selecting for your
filtering and I'm saying level is alert
so it has to not look at all the
information but it has to pull out level
being alert and if you see we already
have these entries which basically tells
me host IP and then you have Source IP
and then you have client IP which is
same so Source IP and client IP are same
what was the bytes in what was the bytes
out right and now you have the alert
level so this was the alert where we
were saying we also look at the
destination IP and it pretty much looks
the same except the one which we see
here
so this one where we are looking at the
information on 23rd August it tells me
alert where host is 251 you have Source
IP which is basically
2.50 we have client IP which is matching
and then you basically have a
destination IP wherein bytes in is 0 and
bytes out is huge and this is something
which we can look at to see if there is
any problem with that so this is a
simple report which we have created and
what we have is we have these different
levels what we are seeing I mean we have
chosen alert as the level now what I
could do is I can add a filter
so or slicer so it says the entities
that columns in the values bucket belong
to are not hierarchically related
because then we can look at the details
here so it says
value bucket or not so we can send
something or
for example we can get rid of the filter
as of now let's just go to the table and
we can basically say okay this is my
level field so we have selected just
this particular data but what we would
be interested in is not information but
might be notice or warning messages so
let's also select warning and then
obviously we can do a count we can find
out
on this information what we are pulling
out so I would want to look at my alert
and warning messages
when your Source IP
and client IP was same
request was originating from host
and we are looking at bytes and bytes
out but I can now look at specific other
information so if you go back here and
if you look into your data set so we
have basically our data set which shows
the source IP because there that was the
filter which has been applied now I can
basically go ahead and say clear filter
here
and that shows me all the entries it
saves me it shows me what is the action
which says accept or information so we
can do a text filtering here where we
can be looking at different values so
let's see what kind of values we have
here and if you carefully see it tells
me that there is this destination
country which is Canada
and your destination country is Hong
Kong Source country something else so we
can be looking for a particular country
we can be looking at if you look at the
DNS apps what is the app here is it a
DNS is it a net bios is it something
else what kind of risk we are talking
about is it a elevated risk are we
talking about duration so we can filter
out this information to reduce our
results because as of now we have
everything so say for example I have my
destination country as Netherlands so
let's go ahead here and I will basically
say
let's go for a filter
and let's say text filter let's say
contains
and now let's say I'm interested only
Netherlands data
so let's say okay
so the filter is applied and now what
you're looking at is just the
Netherlands data for your particular
data set come back to your visualization
so we see the information getting
populated here and we have alert we
should have the
warning messages also
as we have chosen so we are seeing alert
as of now
as the level and we look at a lot of
destination IPS now similarly what I can
be doing is I have this information I'm
looking at the level which is alert now
as I said we can be choosing warning
like we chose earlier now what we can
also do is we can pull out the
information which is based on the total
bytes if we would want to see so let's
basically bring total bytes field
and that should get added to your Visual
and now you see you have the total bytes
values which are showing up for all your
entries here now that's my symbol report
which we have created based on the
fields we can be just looking for
your
Source IP and client IP being same so we
have chosen host because we were
interested in getting the data from our
respective data sets that's your
event which basically has some login for
so now I would be interested in getting
the bytes in or bytes out so let's get
rid of bytes in that's not what I'm
concerned about I would be interested in
looking at the log info
which is basically a consolidation what
we can also do is we already know what
is the destination what is the source IP
what is the client IP which we are
looking at and we know that Source IBN
client IP will be matched so let's
reduce the burden by
getting rid of your client IP here now
if you see we are already seeing some
information which has come in here which
talks about your login for which talks
about configuration was changed who was
the user what what was the IP and we are
basically filtering out the information
I'm still seeing the source IP I'm
looking at the client IP
I am looking at the values where they
are basically matching
so you look at the new data which is
hostname you have alerts you basically
have your destination IP Source IP so we
can always see what is the destination
IP what is the source IP Source IP same
as your client IP remember the bytes and
byte out information
what we are extracting is coming in from
your stream HTTP data and these are if
you just look at the message it clearly
tells me that this is a alert message
and that's why we are seeing
configuration changed now that's the
kind of information we are seeing and
there was a alert generated which was
coming in from source and on this
particular destination server so this
was and there was some bytes in bytes
outgoing and you can look at the total
number of bytes which is a total of
bytes in and bytes out so you can also
calculate what was the bytes in if there
was some kind of acknowledgment which
was sent and this is good information so
we can get rid of alert and let me say
just warning so I would want to select
warning now we are talking about count
of 400 and we will have to give some
time and then we can start saving this
or publishing this report what we can
also do is once we have published the
report we can ask questions to this one
right so it will always be good to
publish the report with all the levels
rather than a particular level because
then it gives you a wide variety of
asking different questions different
kind of log information messages what we
are seeing at so date can be important
device name what we are looking at can
tell me where the data is coming in from
so technically speaking we have bytes
and bites out that's the kind of message
which we are seeing and we are
seeing what is the device name now
device name is basically coming in from
this particular event field and that's
why it is showing up the values here we
don't have any device name
so we can keep the device name or we can
filter it out
so we know that there is a relationship
between host of your 40 gate event and
40 Gate traffic and that's good enough
now I have taken up this example which
looks complex but then it's very useful
in real time machine data where you can
create visualization where you can work
on multiple data sets where you can do
data modeling which basically means that
you can have relationships between
different data sets so that you can
create your visualization you can create
your reports and then basically you can
save or publish those reports so once
this report is generated based on our
these simple data sets we can
continuously improve our data modeling
so right now we just have this
information but what I can do is I can
go for the modeling option here and then
I can basically Mark as date table I can
manage the relationships here I can go
in for a new table new measure so
remember measure is something which you
can create here so these are your
Dimensions or values coming in from
Dimension tables so new measure is
basically if you would want to calculate
something if you would want to calculate
something so for example you want to
calculate how many different destination
IPS are existing or if you would want to
go for a quick measure so choose from a
list of common calculations and add the
results to the selected table so we can
do that so for example let's go for
quick measure and it says okay what is
the calculation you would want so it
says
you can get a average per category
variance per category
you can basically do a count you can get
Max So Max and minimum would not work
might be we can work on bytes data so we
can do that we can say basically your
quarter today total month-to-date total
so you can just go for total for
category so filter supplied and you can
basically go for cat
totals you can do some mathematical
operations if you are interested in you
can concatenate list of values so for
example we can go for
total for category now calculate the
total across all values in a category
applying filters in your report so we
can basically say what is the data field
you would want to work on
so for example let's say the
destination IP
so let me add that here
now this one is category over which do
you want to calculate the total total so
I have destination IP and let's say
Source IP or client IP so that's the
category and I'll say okay
now this is where you are doing a quick
measure where there are list of measures
which we can add so measures if you
remember
Dimension tables are something which
contains the actual data and your
measures are basically what is stored in
the fact table right so fact table has
fields or columns which are already in
your dimension table so your dimension
table has the columns as a primary key
and facts table has the columns as the
foreign key plus your facts table will
have measures
and basically those measures is what you
are trying to calculate which can be
added to your table that is as your
report and then you can publish the
report so this is where we chose a quick
measure and we are doing it now I can
add a new column I can create a new
measure depending on the value so what I
am trying to do here is I'm trying to
say let's find out the count of your
Source IPS and the category which I'm
choosing is destination IPS
so I would want to get a count of
what are the different Source IPS what
are the counts of those and then we can
basically tabulate that so let this
report run and we will have a view edit
and we will then publish this so now if
you look at this messages so we are
looking at our report might be
quite big enough format
so I can basically choose the format by
going in here and we have the general
and background and let's look into
General so it basically gives all text
we can give some details here but let's
look at the grid so first let me
it is still working so sometimes you
have to wait so for example I choose and
then I look into the value so I can go
into the style and I can change the
formatting so the report which we are
running is on huge data set
and that's something which we need to
remember to basically look at the result
or to look at the count of whatever we
are doing it might take some time
but then once it is done we can easily
publish this so after sorting the data
and reducing the data because data was
really huge so it was taking time to
generate the report and publish it so
basically here the report has been
created now we can apply measures to
this if you closely see here I have
applied filters which is alert which
basically tells me just 12 alerts
because we have run a quick measure so I
am looking only for alert level
information and date I have chosen
everything Beyond 27 754 because what I
know is that in my traffic related data
so if you would basically see here in
the traffic related data so we have date
which has been filtered and if I look
into my other data such as http B
I can see the date which exists
here shows 26 because now we have
filtered the data so you have to filter
the data otherwise you might fall short
of memory now here if you see the data
starts from 28 23 51 and then that's the
last one so you can obviously see in a
reverse order or you can sort this by
doing this and that should show you the
starting data
and here if I closely see there are all
the fields
which are showing up but then you can
basically choose how much data you are
pushing in there so the data here is
basically having huge amount of data and
that will affect your visualization so
you have to be careful in what data you
select and how much would go into your
visualization so in my visualization
based on the fields which we have
selected I have
basically limited the amount of data
which can show me in the report however
when we have a bigger server we can
basically create a report with all the
data or the suggestion would be to break
the data sets into smaller chunks and
then go for reports and visualization
now this report was published to my bi
service and if you see here this is my
bi service which has the data I have
applied the similar kind of filters here
and now I can start asking questions
which can then be added to my report so
here I am saying show me the first total
of this CP
total from your s Source IP so I can
look into something like this now if I'm
not interested in this I can delete this
I can ask different questions here so
for example count I can say count
destination IPS
and that tells me there are different
13.44 destination IPS and I can say for
each Source IP the resource IP or the
client IP now you can give a query like
this which will basically try to do a
count of Destiny destination IPS for
your Source IPS and it can give you
account so here it gives me what is the
destination IP for each Source IB and
this one has the highest count and then
you can look at the other values and if
you would want to save this question or
the answer to this question let's put it
here so we can basically make our report
layout a little smaller
or change the format here so that we can
push in more data here or ask more
questions now once this is done I have
my report created with different kind of
filters I can just go ahead and save
this report
remember I have filtered out the data
and I have selected the data fields with
date being just for two days instead of
for two years now that basically affects
my overall data but what we have seen
here is we are looking at our report now
what we can do is we can look for
other information here so we have the
visuals on the canvas we can duplicate
this we can share this we can look at
the view and we can change this we have
the file and we basically have our
reports which is shared now if I go back
to my workspace
that shows me
the dashboards which I have I have some
reports now this is the report here and
this is basically you can look at the
usage metrics you can share the
information you can get some quick
insights which power bi is very powerful
in looking at your data and Gathering
some insights however again remember the
amount of data which is selected will
affect the time consumed in generating
these insights so while this is running
I can go back to my power bi desktop and
I can basically have a look at this I
can look at the data models now these
were the relationships which we created
so if you see this was basically host
and Host this was device name and device
name and here I had the client IP and
the source IP and this was basically my
data model now I could have a fact
stable separately created which of the
columns and then the measures which we
can calculate and then add it to our
facts table now this is basically a
simple example of data modeling you can
play around with the data as I mentioned
you can obviously go to Power bi and if
you would want to look at this data as I
mentioned earlier you can just search
for bot sv1 data set generally these
data sets are used for threat hunting
but then this has a lot of data sets
with different sources and you can get
the data from here you can trim it and
then you can basically use for your
power bi or you can always find data
sets and you can look into kaggle or
other sources where you can get
different kind of data which can be used
now if you see here it basically gives
me some insights and we can choose which
insights we would be interested in so it
says count of the source ports and
basically it gives me that
these IPS or which I know these are DNS
servers have noticeably more Source
ports it gives me count of total bytes
and count of bytes so this is a
correlation between total bytes and
bytes it gives me count of info so what
kind of
information we have on packets in so it
says that there is a lot of information
with packets in being three
now I can scroll down I can see count of
source support and count of info
so you can basically look at count of
total bytes count of info so power bi
has generated all these insights for us
and we have this information now I can
obviously download this so I can
basically go in here and look at this
particular Insight I can open it in a
focused mode and look for more
information and we can choose what we
would want to do with this insights so
if you see here it gives me
when you look at the info what kind of
messages are more that also gives you
information total bytes count of your
destination IPS and I can basically
click on this one it opens up in a
bigger window it tells me this is count
of this types or sorry destination IPS
based on your Source IPS and this is a
great Insight so you can always look
into the insight and then basically work
continue working on this so I can just
do a exit Focus mode I'm back to my
insight I can go back to my workspace I
can look into the reports now remember
when you publish your report
your report comes in here and that
basically gives you
an option to create a report you can
schedule it to refresh and get the newer
data you can basically view related
information of this and so on so this is
how you can use modeling with power bi
and this is a simple example well we can
have more complicated modelings uh
modeling scenarios and we can look at
different data sets in this video we
will learn what power bi dashboard is
we'll understand how to create different
reports in power bi desktop then you
will publish a dashboard on to power bi
service and finally you'll derive
insights from the dashboard now let's
understand what power bi dashboard is
power bi dashboard is a single page
visualization to tell a story here on
the screen you can see there's a
dashboard which has been published on
power bi service there are multiple
charts and graphs that you can see the
visualizations on a dashboard are
generated from reports and each report
is based on one data set a single page
dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualizations you see on the dashboard
are called tiles and each of these tiles
are pin to the dashboard by report
designers today we'll be covering the
following dashboard that you see on the
screen it will be a three page report
where we will be analyzing the
superstore sample data as you can see
there are three tabs now let me move
over to our data set so our Superstore
sample data set is in the form of an
Excel file you can see there are
multiple columns you can see there's
order date shipment date the mode of
shipment customers first name and last
name the segment to which the customer
belong to country of the customer the
city state and if you go towards the end
you can see that the different product
names the sales quantity sold discount
and the profit so the report that you
see here and the one which we are going
to create might vary a little in terms
of the color formatting and the spacing
so you need not worry about that now let
me go ahead and bring up a new workspace
so I'll go to file click on new this
will take some time to bring up our new
workspace now it will ask you for trying
the free version or if you want you can
go ahead and sign in I'll just close
this so here is a a new workspace before
creating the dashboard we need to make
some changes to our Superstore data set
using the features of power bi desktop
first we'll extract the year month and
quarter values from the order date
column I'll go to get data tab click on
Excel as my source I'll locate my file
it's on desktop click on open this might
take some time to load the data set I'll
select the orders sheet you can see the
preview of our data here I'll go ahead
and click on load this will take some
time to load the data set onto power bi
desktop I think we have successfully
loaded our data set you can check that
by going to the data tab so here is our
data set first let's make some changes
in the format of the order date and the
shipment date I'll click on the order
date under the modeling tab
we have this data type and the format
I'll click on the drill down option
and the date and time now let's choose
the first one which is in the format of
DDM why why
click on it
as you can see our order date column has
been changed to that particular format
similarly I'll select the ship date
column
go to the format option under date and
time I click on the first one
here you can see even the ship date
column has been changed to that
particular format now let's extract the
month values from the order date column
to do that right click on the order date
column
select new column
so this will create a new column if you
go to the end so there's a new column
rename this column as month and since we
want the month value from the order date
column I'll search for order date
dot since I want the month I'll select
month if I hit enter
it will give me the month values from
the order date column
similarly if you want to get the quarter
values from the order date right click
select new column
rename the column as quarter
then choose the order date column
followed by the quarter name hit enter
so you can see you have a quarter column
and it has all the values of the quarter
to which the date belongs to now let me
go ahead and create one more column
this time we'll create a new column for
the order year this time we'll extract
the order year values so let me rename
it as year we'll continue with the same
procedure I look for the order date and
then select the year
hit enter
so it gives you only the EO values on
which the order was placed
now let's find which day of the week was
the order placed so we need to use the
weekday function and give the order
data's parameter followed by which day
you want the week to start with I'll
show you how to do that so I'll click on
order date
then select new column
let's rename this column as day of week
I'll use the weekday function of power
bi you can hit tab to finish I look for
my order date column
comma
I'll choose 2 here since I want my week
to start with Monday and end on a Sunday
hit enter
so you can see we have the day of the
week column
so the idea to create this day of week
column is to find out if the order was
placed on a weekday or a weekend now let
me go ahead and create one more new
column
let's name this column as
weekday
or a weekend
I'll use an if clause
and pass in my parameters for logical
test I'll use the day of the week column
so I'll search for orders
and then look for day of week if this
day of the week is equal to 6 which
means if it's a Saturday or I'm using
the or operator
if the day of week is a Sunday that is 7
then
it's a weekend
else it's a big day
close the bracket hit enter so you can
see we have our weekday and weekend
column so moving ahead another thing we
can do is we can find the total number
of days it took for the shipment of the
product this can be done using the
dative function of power bi so let me
show you how you can do that I'll click
on any column right click go to new
column let's rename the column as
days for shipment then I'll use the date
div function
I'll give my starting date which is the
order date so I'll search for
order date
followed by the second date will be our
shipment date which is ship date and the
day
I'll hit enter
so you can see here it gives us the
total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product now let's create
a full name column where we will
concatenate the first name and the last
name of the customer let me go ahead and
do that
I'll create a new column
let me rename the column as full name
then I'll take the first name
from the orders table use the Amber sent
followed by a space using inverted
commas followed by another Ampersand and
the last name
I hit enter
you can see we have a full name column
if you go back so there were two columns
in the name of first name and last name
now we have merged both the columns into
a single column named full name and you
can see the first name space and the
last name now let me give the sales
column
a currency value so I'll select the
sales column
here
under General
if I go to currency I can see there are
multiple currency symbols
choose whatever you want for this video
I'll take dollar English United States
you can see our sales column is now
represented by a dollar value similarly
let me make some changes to the profit
column as you can see there are multiple
decimal values for each profit so let's
standardize it
so I'll select the profit column and
this is where you can standardize it now
it's Auto so let me make it two decimal
places
so our data is ready now let's go to the
report View and start building our
reports
before that
under the model view you can see the new
columns that we had created you can see
there's weekday weekend this year
this quarter column month column
the same you can see under the report
view as well under fields you can see
these are the columns that we created
days of shipment day of week
quarter
month weekday or weekend and year now we
are under the report view first let me
go ahead and create a text box
so under the Home tab you have the text
box
I'll select that
let me stretch it a bit
we'll give a title
sales
dashboard I'll select this and increase
the size to
let's say 28 we make it bold
and Center align it also under the
visualizations tab under background
will add a background color to this text
box let me select this blue color and
let me make
the font as white
so now we have our title ready
so under General you can decrease the
height of the text box let me make it as
first let us create a new card from the
visualizations panel so under
visualizations there is an option to
create new card I'll click on it let me
resize
I'll move it to the top
we'll see the total amount of sales or
the total revenue that was generated
from the sales after selecting the card
I'll choose sales onto fields
so here you can see it gives you the
total sales that were made so which is
nearly 2.3 million dollars
if I go to the format tab under data
label
let me switch on the border under title
you can give a new title for example
total
Revenue hit enter
now you can
increase the text size to say 15 and
Center Line it you can also change the
color of the sales value so under data
label under colors you can choose
whichever color you want
similarly let's create one more card to
find the total number of units that were
sold I'll copy the same card
Ctrl C Ctrl V
I'll move it a little below
now I'll remove the sales column
from the fields and add the quantity
column onto fields
again
under title I'll edit this title as
total
quantity sold
let me create one more card
where we will see the total amount of
profit that were made I'll select this
I'll remove the quantity column
and add profit
under the format tab
under title
I'll make this as
total
profit
hit enter
stretch it a bit so that you can see the
total amount of profit that were made
now
let me add a slicer
wherein
will have the order date column
so I'll add the order date column onto
fields
so you can see here we have the order
date column and
under slicer header let me increase the
text size
to 15
and
let's switch on the border
you can also give a title to the slicer
so under the format tab to go to title
switch it on
and we'll give a title text as
slicer by
order date
scroll down I'll Center align it and
increase the text size to 15.
now if you want you can also change the
date colors to Blue so under date inputs
then go to font color and select any
blue color
now let's create a line and stack column
chart visualize sales and profit by each
year each month and each quarter so from
the visualizations tab let me select
line and stack column chart
I'll resize this
after that let me add the order date
column onto the shared axis
we'll drag the sales onto column values
and underline values I'll take the
profit column
so here you can see we have the sales
and profit by each year
the bars represent the sales and this
line represents the profit it made for
each year let me go to the format tab
and
make some changes to the data colors let
the color of the profit remain the same
but the bars I'll choose a custom color
give a hexadecimal value like
hit enter
so we have successfully changed the
color of the bars power bi has an
interesting feature where you can drill
down the seals by each year each month
each quarter or by days so let me show
you so on the top it shows you go to the
next level in the hierarchy so if I
click on this
here you can see the sales and the
profit that were made for each quarter
in every year
quarter four for every year made the
highest amount of sales and the profit
similarly if I drill down further you
can see let me expand it you can see by
month this is for each month
over all the years how much sales were
made
you can check November month give us the
highest amount of sales and
December month gave us the highest
amount of profit
similarly you can still go to the next
hierarchy here you can see
the sales and the profit made for each
day over all the years so day 17 made
the highest amount of sales
and day 23 gave us the highest amount of
profit if you see the lowest sales and
the profit you can see order date 25
gave us the lowest amount of profit
and similarly you can see day 29 gave us
the lowest amount of sales
now you can also go to the format tab
and switch on the data labels
so you can see here in 2014 we got
nearly 49.5 K profit and nearly 0.48
million dollar sales similarly in 2015
we had nearly 61.6 K profit and 0.47
million sales and so on
now let me go ahead to the format Tab
and
switch on the border let me now create a
clustered column chart for sales by year
and quarter so from the visualizations
let's select clustered column chart let
me resize this a bit
and under access
will add the year column
so I'll drag here on to access under
Legend I'll take the quarter column
and under values I'll choose sales
so you can see here the sales that were
made under each quarter for each year
this picture clearly says quarter 4 for
every year Meet the highest amount of
sales and quarter one
made the lowest
let me go to the format tab
and I'll go to the data colors let's
change the colors for each of these
quarters we'll be using hexadecimal
values so under custom colors for
quarter one
let me select hexadecimal value as
follows so for example PF D6 D9
similarly for Quarter Two
I'll select 6D 9 ba6
for quarter 3
and finally for quarter 4
I choose a little darker color
so here is how our clustered column
chart looks like and we can see the
sales by year and quarter
now let me go ahead and
let's add a border now
we'll analyze the seals by each state so
for that we'll use field map so I'll
click on field map
let me resize it
now let me add the state column onto
location
and the tool tips I'll
add the sales column
let me expand it so you can see here we
have the map which shows the sales by
each state
now let's do some color formatting to
this I'll go to the format tab click on
ADD colors
and blue is the default color there is
an additional option
where you can use conditional formatting
so I'll use that so it gives you the
option to choose your color between
maximum value and the minimum value you
can also choose this diverging option
where you get a center value or a mid
value as well now for the minimum value
I'll choose a color again I'll use a
custom color it will be similar to a
green color
red okay then
let's use some orange color for the Mid
Valley range for example EB
and similarly for the maximum value
we'll use a little darker color which
looks similar to red
click enter so now we have defined our
color scheme
let's click on OK
let's zoom out so you can see the states
which are in green color meet the lowest
amount of sales while those which are in
orange or in red meet the highest amount
of sales so in this example you can see
California had the highest amount of
sales similarly New York is next is just
below California with the amount of
sales followed by Texas we'll go back
let me also
add a border to this similarly you can
also select the profit column or the
unit sold column to see the units or the
profit that were sold by each state
so let me now go ahead and create a
donut chart in the donut chart we'll
analyze the sales and profit by each
segment
so under visualizations I click on donut
chart
so under Legend I'll add the segment
column
under values I'll take the sales column
and
we also want the profit so I'll take
The Profit column onto tooltips
so you can see we have our donor chart
prepared and you can see the sales and
profit by each segment
let me expand this the donut chart
indicates consumer segment made the
highest amount of sales and profit while
home office segment made the lowest
I'll go back
let me go to the format tab
and we'll make some formatting to our
data let's change the color of all the
segments
choose custom color
let's give a color
coding as
1558c
similarly we change
the color for corporate segment as well
let's take a gray color
and finally we'll change the color for
home office as well
I'll also switch on the border
so we have our donor chart prepared now
let's move ahead and create a pie chart
to analyze the profit and sales by each
category of products so under
visualizations I'll select pie chart
I'll drag the category column onto
Legend
under values I'll take the profit column
and under tooltips I'll take the sales
column
so you can see we have a simple pie
chart that tells you the profit and the
sales that were made by each category
as it's evident category technology made
the highest amount of sales and profit
while Furniture category made the lowest
amount of profit and sales
I'll go back
under format I'll change the data Colors
Let's go ahead and do that
I'll use custom colors and give
a hexadecimal color value
similarly for office supplies I'll take
another hexadecimal value
and finally we'll change the color of
the furniture category
also
let's give a border
so we have a pie chart prepared that
tells you the profit and sales by each
category of products now we are done
with our first sales dashboard so I can
go ahead
and rename
this tab as
overall sales
next we are going to analyze the sales
profit quantity sold and all of these
by taking region and the state as
filters so we'll continue with the same
drill first I'll create a text box
so under home menu I'll go to text box
I'll stretch this
I'll give a title to this page for
example region
and
state
level analysis
let me make it bold
and
I'll increase the size to 28
make it Center aligned
will make the text
as white
and
the visualizations
let's give a background color
I choose this blue color
so let me go ahead and create three
slicers a region slicer a state slicer
and a ear slicer so under visualizations
I'll click on slicer
let me resize
move it on top
and
for region slicer I need to add region
onto fields
so you can see we have a region filter
now
let's do some formatting to this
under slicer header
let me make the font color
white and
let's give a background
let's say blue
and let me increase the text size to
say 15.
you can also choose a font family
let's go for calibri
and
you can increase the size
of the items let's increase the text
size
to
say 15.
and
let's give a border
so now you have the region slicer ready
let me copy paste this
next
we'll create the state slicer so I'll
remove region from here and add
State onto the field
you can see we have the state slicer
ready similarly
you can also go ahead
and create a ear slicer
but you can analyze the sales and profit
or quantity by year
I'll remove State from here
and
I'll drag the ear column onto field
you can see we have all the four years
from 2014 to 2017. so sometimes it might
be difficult for you to scroll through
all the values present in a slicer for
example in the state slicer
you can see there are multiple States
and if you want to filter your report by
a particular State you have to always
scroll down or scroll up and check
manually where the state is so power bi
gives you this feature where you can use
the search option so if I click on this
you can see there's a search option
select that so now
in the search bar you can search for any
state you are looking for for example if
you want to search for California state
you can just type on California so you
have just type Cal and it shows me
California that's an important feature
that power bi gives you
so let me now go ahead and create a
simple table where we will see the
quantity and the profit made in each
City so under visualizations I'll select
tables
let me resize this
so under values first I'll add the city
column
followed by
the quantity column
and
The Profit column
let's do some formatting
so under column headers
let me change the font color to white
and let's add a background
let me increase the text size also
let's make it 15
similarly if you scroll down under
values
let's increase the text size
to 15 as well
and
let's choose the font family let's take
consoles
so here
you can see all the cities
the quantity
sold in each City and the profit that
was made in each of these cities
let me add a border to this
so now you can filter each of these
cities by region or by state
for example if I choose Central
as my region
it will give you all the cities that lie
in the central region
similarly
you can also search for any state for
example
I am taking Minnesota
so under Minnesota
you can see all the cities and the
quantity as well as the profits made
let me now uncheck the filters now let
me go ahead and filter this table
in terms of profit so I'll sort by
profit
you can see
we have our cities sorted in terms of
profit
so New York City made the highest amount
of profit followed by Los Angeles and
Seattle below you can see the total
units that were sold and the total
profit that was made from all the cities
so you can also filter down the quantity
sold and the profit made by each year as
well as by region and State
so let's see suppose I am choosing
East as the region
so under East it tells you the states
that are present
let's
go for Delaware
and let's select 2016 as my year
so you can see
the cities that lie under delivery state
and the quantity as well as the profit
they made in 2016. similarly let's
select
Massachusetts as the state and let's
go for another year for example 2017
you can see all the cities that are
present under Massachusetts the quantity
sold and the profit that was made below
you can see the total quantity and the
profit
let me uncheck all these
now moving ahead let's analyze the sales
by each state and the category of
product for this
will create a clustered bar chart so
under visualizations I'll select
clustered bar chart let me resize a bit
under access
I'll take the state column
I'll take category onto Legend
and under values
help of the sales column
so you can see here
we have the seals for each category
under each state
for example California state made the
highest amount of sales under technology
category and it made the lowest amount
of sales under office supplies
if I scroll down you can see all the
states
and the sales they made
for each category
I'll go back to the report
now let's use some filters
you can filter here for example if I
want to check
the sales by each state and category for
2015 I can just
click on 2015
and it will tell you the sales that were
made
now
let's do some formatting to this bar
chart
I'll change the colors for each of the
categories
similarly we change the color for office
supplies
and finally for the technology
so now we have our bar chart ready
moving on now let me add a border to
this bar chart
okay
so now that we have seen our sales by
state and category let's now check the
profit by year and category for that
we'll create an area chart
I'll resize this chart
now
under axis
I'll take the year column
under Legend
I'll take the category column
and
the values
I'll take profit
so we have our area chart that depicts
The Profit by each year and the category
to which the product belong to
I'll go to the format Tab and under data
colors
I'll choose some colors
let's change Furniture to this blue
color
I'll take office supplies a red color
and Technology I'll use a green color
so now you can use the filters
for example you can check the profit
that was made by each year and category
under east region
so you can see here
in 2017 technology meet the highest
amount of profit while furniture at the
lowest
similarly
let's
check for South Region
so you can see in south region in 2016
technology meet the highest amount of
profit
and
furniture made the lowest in 2017 office
supplies made the highest amount of
profit and Furniture was the lowest
I'll uncheck this South Region filter
similarly you can also see the sales by
each state so under State slicer you can
choose whichever State you want and
check the profit it made by that year or
category
for example I'll choose Connecticut
so you can see the profit Connecticut
state made in each of these years
I'll uncheck it
let us move ahead and now let's see
profit that was made and the quantity
that was sold by each category and
subcategory of the product so for this
I'll choose the line and clustered
column chart so I'll select from the
visualizations now
under shared access
I'll select the category column under
column series I'll take the subcategory
column
under column values I'll choose profit
and
I'll choose quantity
under the tooltips
so now you can see
The Profit that was made under each
category and the subcategory
for technology category copiers
subcategory made the highest amount of
profit the quantity sold was 234.
similarly
if you check for furniture category
we didn't make any profit for table
subcategory
and as well as for bookcases
under office supplies paper subcategory
made the highest amount of profit
now let me go ahead and add a border to
this
fine
moving ahead now we will see the sales
by each segment for that let's create a
funnel so from visualizations I'll take
the
funnel and
I'll drag
segment onto group
and the sales column onto values
so you can see here
the sales that were made by each segment
this picture clearly depicts that
consumer segment with the highest amount
of sales next was corporate and then
home office
now
let's do some color formatting so the
default color is this blue
I'll click on so all
now we'll give individual colors to each
of the segments
using custom color
let's give a hexadecimal value
similarly we'll change the color for the
corporate segment
and finally for the home office segment
now let me go ahead and give a border to
it
so if you want to analyze the seals by
segment and for
a particular region or state or any
particular year you can do that so let's
select
for each region
and
let's take New Jersey as the state
for year 2014 suppose
so you can see here corporate segment
meet the highest amount of sales
followed by consumer and home office
let me uncheck
these filters
so our second report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity profit at
Region level state level and by year so
I can rename this
as
a region and State
next we will analyze the sales quantity
profit in terms of categories and
subcategory of products so let me first
copy this text box
and create a new tab
I'll paste that text box here and
change the title to
say
category
and
sub category level analysis
first
we'll create a
slicer
where we will take
the category as filter
so if I want I can directly copy it
from my previous tab
and change the fields so let me copy
this
and paste it here
I'll sync it
and let me remove the region field and
add
category onto the field
so you can see
we have the three categories here
let me copy paste this again and
let me take the subcategory now
so I'll select this
and
I'll drag subcategory onto the field so
here you can see we have all the
subcategories and above we have the
categories
let me resize this a bit
with that now let's analyze the sales
and profit by region and segment
to do this we'll use a tree map so let's
see how you can build a tree map under
visualizations I have tree map let me
select it
and move it to the top
and expand it a bit
now
under group
I'll select region column
under details I'll take
segment
I'll take the sales column under values
and let's take profit
on two tooltips
so if I expand this
you can see the sales and profit by each
region and segment for example in the
west region you have consumer corporate
and home office
as the segments and you can see consumer
segment meet the highest amount of sales
and profit while home office made the
lowest amount of sales and profit
similarly you can check for the other
regions as well
now
let's give a border to the Stream app
and
under data colors let me change the
color of the regions
scroll down
custom color let me choose my own color
let's take this as a gray color
and finally
for the best region
so now you can select individual
categories and subcategories to check
the sales and profit by region and
segment for example
if I select
Furniture as my category
you can see the changes that were made
to the tree map
you can also select office supplies and
see
how the sales and profit changes
similarly you can also go ahead and
select whatever subcategories you want
and then check the sales and profit by
region and segment with that let me now
create a pie chart
to see the quantity and the sales by
each segment
so I'll go and select a pie chart
let me resize this
if you want you can increase the size of
this tree map also
so let me go ahead
and select segment onto the legend
under values I'll take quantity
and
sales under tooltips
so this pie chart
depicts the quantity and the sales that
were made by each segment as you can see
consumer segment meet the highest amount
of sales and had the highest quantity
sold
while home office had the least number
of quantities sold and the least number
of sales
let's add a border
and
change the data colors
similarly I change the color for the
corporate segment let's make this
Gray
and home office
I'll take the following color
move this a little to the right
now let's build a scatter plot to
analyze the sales quantity and profit by
each subcategory
so under visualizations
I'll select scatter plot I'll resize
this
so I'll add
sub category onto Legend
then I'll add sales onto the x-axis
quantity sold onto the y-axis
and under size
will take the profit column
if I expand this
you can see the sales quantity and the
profit that was made for each
subcategory of products you can see here
subcategory phone has given us a
significant amount of sales with less
number of quantities sold and it has
given us a good amount of profit also
similarly subcategory shares has also
given us good amount of sales with close
to 2356 quantities sold and a good
amount of profit if you see this one
which is subcategory paper it gave us
less amount of sales with more
quantities sold while it gave us good
amount of profit though so you may
promote phones or for example chairs to
sell more since it gives you more amount
of profit with less quantity sold
let's add a border to this
you can use the category filter suppose
if I choose for furniture
and expand this
you can see
under Furniture subcategory Furnishings
give us the lowest amount of sales with
the highest number of quantities sold
but it gave us a decent amount of profit
subcategory tables gave us a decent
amount of sales with lesser number of
quantities sold but didn't give us any
profit
subcategory cheers give us the highest
amount of sales and also the profit
I'll uncheck this
let's now create a line chart where we
can see the profit by each year and
quarter so under visualizations
I'll select line chart let me resize
this
so under access
I'll take year
and a legend
I'll take the quarter column
and under values
I'll take the profit column
so now you can see
The Profit that was made
each year and the lines depict each
quarter
so if you check for 2014 quarter four
meet the highest amount of profit while
quarter 2 made the lowest amount of
profit while quarter 1 made the lowest
amount of profit similarly if you see
for 2016 you can see
quarter four meet the highest amount of
profit
while quarter One Meet the lowest
if you check for 2017 you see a quarter
three and quarter four almost meet the
same amount of profit while
quarter 2 made the lowest amount of
profit
I go back
now you can filter these by categories
also suppose if I see for technology
you can check the amount of profit that
was made in each year and in each
quarter for technology category
let's add a border to this
likewise we'll now create another line
chart that will depict the sales by each
year and quarter
so let me copy paste this
I'll drag this to the right
now I'll remove
profit from values and add sales
let me uncheck this also
so here you can see we have the sales by
each year and quarter
now if you see for 2014 again quarter
four meet the highest amount of sales
and quarter 1 in 2014 meet the lowest
you will see for 2016 you can see 2016
also quarter for me the highest amount
of sales and quarter One Meet the lowest
and go back
so our final report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity sold the
profit at category and subcategory level
I can go ahead and rename this as
category
and sub category
let me see this now if you want
you can also filter it by sub categories
for example if I select
shares as my subcategory
so for chairs you can see the sales that
was made by each year and quarter
so in 2017 quarter four made the highest
amount of seals while quarter one made
the lowest amount of sales for cheers
similarly
you can select other subcategories also
for example
let me take
some other category like
machines
let's see the profit now
so for machine subcategory you can see
in 2014 quarter four meet the highest
amount of profit while
quarter 3
meet the lowest amount of profit
now if you check for 2015 you can see
quarter three meet the highest amount of
profit in shares while quarter 1 made
the lowest amount of profit
let's uncheck this
so now we are almost done building our
report using the superstore sample data
set
so we have our three reports ready you
can see the first one was overall sales
the second report we created
by taking region State and the year as
filters so we had a region and state
level analysis and finally we analyzed
the sales quantity and the profit sold
by category and subcategory so I have
arranged all these graphs and charts so
that it looks little better now let me
go to this publish option on the top so
that we can publish this report onto the
power bi Dash code
so I'll click on publish
I'll save it
you can select the destination here I
have only one destination which is my
workspace so I'll choose it and select
so there you go publishing to power bi
it was successful
I'll close it
and let me move to my power bi service
I'll refresh it for once
so under my workspace
you can see we have the dashboard report
So Below you can see there are three
tabs that we created the first one is
overall sales
the second one is sales by region the
third one is by category and subcategory
now to put this reports onto the
dashboard I need to pin each one of
these visualizations
so let me pin one by one
so it asks where would you want to pin
it to I'll select the existing dashboard
or better let's create a new dashboard
let's say
power bi
Dash code
spin it
close this
similarly let's spin the remaining ones
I'll select power bi dashboard again pin
it
let's spin everything
so this slides that you can't pin it
let's do the remaining ones
same will do for the donut chart
as well as
for the pie chart
now
now if I go to
my dashboards
and select power bi dashboard
you can see
we have a one page
dashboard here
you can resize all the charts and graphs
let me resize it
and move it to the top
so we have our first canvas here
which tells you the overall sales the
profit and the units that were sold over
different states different segments and
by categories so one of the important
feature that power bi service gives you
is that you can ask questions about your
data and it will tell you what the exact
solution is for example you can see here
you have a field where you can ask
questions so for example if I type
total sales
and hit enter
so it tells you the total amount of
sales that were made which is 2.3
million dollars similarly if I want to
find out the total
profit I can search for it here
hit enter it will give you the exact
amount of profit that was made let's do
something else for example if you want
total
profit
by
say here
I'll hit enter it gives you a nice line
chart where you can see the total profit
that was made over all the four years
next
suppose I searched for total
quantity
sold
by
segment
see it gives me a bar chart where you
can see the total quantity that was sold
and it gives you a list of options where
you can find out the total quantity that
was sold by city state order ID first
name last name and many others so
consumer segment had the highest
quantity sold
let's see it's for something else for
example if you want
the total
sales by
say subcategory
I'll choose the first one
see you have all the subcategories and
the total sales that they made so it's a
very interesting feature that power bi
gives you go back
now if you want
you can go to the report menu
and if you want you can pin the other
visualizations as well
so another important feature about power
bi dashboard is that you can derive
insights from the visualization for
example
if I click on these dots there's an
option you find view insights I'll
select it
so on the right you can see Power bi has
itself given us some insights from the
data and the visualizations we have made
you can see sales by year and quarter
the sales by day of week and quarter
sales by shipment mode where you can see
the standard classic Mode made the
highest amount of sales
you can also see the sales and count of
City by year
and many more now that brings us to the
end of this live session on power bi
full course I hope you liked it if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comment section below
also don't forget to subscribe to the
simply learn Channel stay tuned for more
from Simply learn